[Laughter]
foreign
hey everybody what's going on it's
Friday yeah and we're doing our regular
Friday thing yep we're getting you guys
ready for the weekend whether you're
staying in or you're going out or
whatever we're gonna [ __ ] warm it up
some of you guys are just [ __ ]
commuting or a lot of people [ __ ] uh
listen to us when we're commute when
they're commuting so you know either way
[ __ ] we'll hook you up we're gonna
get you ready for this weekend just sit
back and relax
[Laughter]
and relax [ __ ] get your popcorn
I was at the biker bar already so I
pre-gamed a little bit yeah yeah I'm
only just now getting started Amy Amy
poured me two doubles and [ __ ]
somebody bought one of those doubles for
me so I only had to pay for one double
aim is to charge me a price for a single
because that's how she is
and uh so I gave her a ten dollar tip
she loves you yeah she had her boobs out
and everything today all them girls were
taking her clothes off while like
completely out that's how it is
trying to flash [ __ ] and [ __ ] you
know between each and they get drunk
just [ __ ] biker women you know
they're like the Klingons it's like
there's Klingon you may not want to see
it you don't really want to see it half
the time you're like nah nah but they
just they just do what they want to do
well I mean a lot of those guys are in
their 60s and [ __ ] so they're just happy
to see anything you know
isn't that kind of always the way like
everybody always gets excited when
they're younger it's like oh let's go to
the nudist beach and then it's like a
bunch of people that you wouldn't want
to do like it's a bunch of like old fat
saggy people yeah yeah
half time which you know whatever I'm
not you know we got Louie Mr Hernandez
is in the uh chat yeah have you have you
been in the show I feel like this was
the first time in the chat and we tried
to like um we wanted to thank you
specifically for sending us Pulp Fiction
and Reservoir Dogs yeah yeah and we're
gonna uh we're gonna we did Reservoir
Dogs already we're gonna do Pulp Fiction
here we're gonna see that probably
tomorrow
yeah so we'll probably review that
Sunday and then also we had a request to
do the hateful eight as well so we'll
probably do that on Tuesday I imagine
because like no well next week is
Christmas week so we'll kind of figure
out I wanted to kind of do some
Christmassy horror movies if I have time
I was like I feel like
I've just gotten so behind I guess it
happened like because of Thanksgiving I
guess and it's like I got behind with a
couple of videos and now I'm like behind
with a bunch of videos so I've just
gotten to a point where I'm like
whatever like whenever we do them
because honestly we should have put up
um you know our movie retrospective on
Chinatown That was supposed to get
recorded today but it didn't happen it
kind of ran out of time for it so I was
like man I need to go to the [ __ ] bar
hey
who's out tonight
or today it's daytime [ __ ] that biker
that bike is just daytime [ __ ] a lot of
times
um but we'll try it Friday and Sunday
we'll try and do it over the weekend and
I wanted to post I wanted to do a video
on um because you know I've been doing
over on my scare Salon Channel if you're
not subscribed over there
um I've been doing uh my top five
favorite horror movies from every year
since I was born so I've been wanting to
do I got to do the 1979 one so I'm gonna
have to put that up sometime this
weekend maybe and I'm a couple weeks
behind on book reviews as well
um I'm in the middle of reading one
right now I'm probably about 60 of the
way in it and I had another book of like
Christmas horror stories called bah
humbug that I wanted to read like and
put up right around Christmas time so
hopefully I'll get to that but it's just
the one that I'm reading now it's really
good but it's just like don't have like
a lot of time to read it and it's kind
of long so I'll eventually get around to
it but I'm trying like I said I'm trying
not to like beat myself up about like
being behind on everything because it's
just I'm the only one that you know has
the schedule for them up and then you
know it's hard for me to just be like oh
well I can just put them up whenever
David Parker they're done our friend
David Parker I don't know if you are you
going to uh mannequins tonight we're
probably yeah he says mannequins we're
probably not going out tonight I don't
think we're not going out the money's
too tight I mean yeah I am broken [ __ ]
money's too tight I mean like really bro
because if we go out there we're gonna
spend 100 bucks yeah that's like that is
100 bucks I absolutely do not have so
you know what I mean
um oh and Tammy is here as well and this
afternoon we got this awesome Christmas
card from Miss Tammy yeah I'm just
finding out about this now I wasn't here
for this well yeah it just came in the
mail like this afternoon yeah so it's
got a little grunchy on it I never
realized that the Grinch had had little
belly Pockets look at look at that is it
a pockets on his belly he's got pockets
on it that's pretty convenient please
put his chains you know right and his
keys and whatnot in his cell phone
like Chris's cell phone
but yeah
should we read it it doesn't say it
doesn't say anything embarrassing well I
mean this is just like a quote it's like
every who done in Whoville liked
Christmas a lot but the Grinch Who Lived
just north of Whoville did not
so um she says wishing the two of you
the best holiday season and may your
channels only grow and your money grow
more yeah I hope that money I mean from
your lips to God's ears I'm just saying
okay
um thanks for the many hours of
entertainment and even more laughter and
a loving hello to Pookie and Beijing
thank you thank you and you're a loyal
fan and supporter always Miss Tammy
appreciate it thank you very much that
is really really sweet he's right there
Pookie say thank you okay she blanked
thinking is yes or I love you thank you
it's something blinking is just a
response how you doing
there you go all right yeah yeah
although she will if she does talk if
you like say something to her she'll say
something back to you you know what I
mean yeah is she she's pissed she wants
in the closet he's saying no she's no no
no no no no
she [ __ ] screams no she was screaming
no today really well you saw I heard you
well that was last night it was last
night yeah yeah yeah yes last night no
no because I wouldn't let her in
well because if you let her in she tears
up your shoes yeah yeah she just goes in
there to try to rape [ __ ] shoes and
boots
and you're saying you tell her no don't
do it and she just looks dead at you I'm
gonna do it
I gotta do it
she'll tear it's addiction she'll tear
up [ __ ] 400 pair of new rack boots
yeah but she well she at least has the
sense to go around the back because she
thinks that you can't see her yeah she
did that yesterday yeah
don't do it don't do it she's I'm not
doing it I'm not doing it you can't see
it you can't see me I'm over on the
other side of the boots even though you
could clearly see it clearly see it
she's smart but she's not that smart
foreign
it's Friday it is yeah another Friday
and on Fridays it's kind of like open
lines we can talk about whatever you
guys want to talk about and just drop
questions in the chat room in the chat
and uh
we'll talk about it
could be anything if you got questions
if you've got questions about any of the
cases that we covered uh any you know
personal questions about [ __ ] the
kind of [ __ ] we like to do or habits or
whatever we can talk about that
um if you have any questions about
[ __ ] Fitness or [ __ ] steroids or
guns or in motorcycles anything like
that I can get on that just you know
it's open lines you guys know the deal
it's open lives yeah ask our opinions on
anything
can I just say speaking of well I was
going to say speaking of Fitness but in
a very very oblique kind of way I don't
know if you saw that ridiculous ass
movie that I was watching on Rift tracks
last night I saw updates of it oh my it
looked like something I [ __ ] would
have liked when I was a kid
is yeah I mean it was called deadly prey
yeah I can't remember the name of the
dude that was it was clearly kind of
like a Rambo rip-off sort of it was like
mercenaries and then like the guy like
this guy who used to be in the
mercenaries or used to be in the guy
that ran the mercenaries he got
kidnapped yeah beef for reasons and then
they were like hunting him for sport or
for training or something like that
except he kicked all their asses it's a
it sounds like a Rambo and he just like
yeah it's so it but he ran around like
the entire time like with his glistening
pecs and also like with some cut off
denim shorts okay yeah like he didn't
even like ever put any clothes on and
it's like so funny because like the rift
tracks guys are like he's like all the
dudes he killed it's like you think that
he would at least like take some clothes
take a poncho or something but it's like
he never did he just ran around Barefoot
with like did he have a bandana tied
around his head he did not but he had
um a pretty sweet mullet with kind of
like a really bad
um he had like a Jerry like no it was
like Roots you know what I mean like he
had bleached it at some point in the
past but he hadn't bleached it for a
while so it was kind of like dark and
dark dark dark dark dark dark blonde
blonde blonde but not like it was
frosted like not on purpose right you
know what I'm saying she was supposed to
be [ __ ] styling supposed to be
styling I mean everybody had mullets in
this movie I don't know what it's I mean
it was when you call it a mullet it was
just hair
we didn't call it a bullet it was just
yeah that's why we were we were ignorant
to it we were ignorant to the
mullification of the of the planet and
mollified sorry I just had like a really
funny momental image of like the Earth
with a big mullet
you know
oh my God yeah you should um for some
reason like I like all the riftrax
movies that they do but for some reason
like the 80s ones or and the 70s ones
are funny too but it's like the 80s ones
are usually like the most entertaining
at least to me well that's yeah but I
just like black people had mullets
that's how bad everybody did well I
didn't know Rick James had him well it
would be everybody
speaking of personal questions David
June says does Tom ever bust out the BTK
voice in the bedroom if so how quick
does Jenny run away no I never think of
BTK I don't think you've ever done that
I don't think you've ever done I never
think of BTK until you guys mentioned it
on the show
no he's lying
that he's always thinking of me
you wish Dennis yeah yeah that [ __ ]
still alive right yeah I asked that
every single time don't I you know
I could always use some money to send to
my store account
buy some cigarettes trade them
trade him for what Dennis ass yeah
that's what I figured boy [ __ ]
it's so early too well you've already
been drinking so yeah it's probably
[ __ ] Dennis [ __ ] Dennis no one's
[ __ ] Dennis [ __ ] Dennis no one
should [ __ ] dinner
those pictures of Dennis that he took of
himself
in [ __ ] women's underwear down in the
ground what was he [ __ ] thinking
about [ __ ] crazy
you thought that was some sexy [ __ ]
yeah that's a little you know oh it
wasn't me
all right Dennis why are you getting in
the ground man [ __ ] women
stockings and [ __ ] [ __ ] garters and
[ __ ] Merry Widow [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know [ __ ] I wasn't me that was the
impersonator
now somebody pretended to be me I do
that you believe anything
CIA set me up
yeah that
was FBI okay Johnson said Can anyone
actually pull off a mullet
um
yeah I guess
I don't really know I can't really think
of I mean some of the
I guess some of the less mullety mullets
yeah Andrew Eldridge from the sisters
yeah that were like more on the new wave
and the Spectrum like some of those
looked okay like they weren't great but
they looked better than yeah once they
got super ridiculous where it was just
kind of like super short in the back and
then it was like really long and fluffy
like in the back the the [ __ ] the the
[ __ ] the main mullet okay the [ __ ]
mullet by which all other mullets were
[ __ ] judged the mullet nature [ __ ]
the uh what do you call it
the central mullet the platonic idea
[Laughter]
the bullet at the center of the Galaxy
was the [ __ ] mullet that the lead
singer of the catchy Goose had remember
that mullet yeah yeah yeah yeah that was
kind of a modify well I guess
technically technically it was a new
wave mullet it was a spiky mullet it was
spiky on the top it was black and it had
[ __ ]
um blonde ends yeah like frosted tips
yeah and it was long in the back and
short on the side just look at the
[ __ ] everything [ __ ] two the two
Shy video yeah lamal that guy's name the
mall was well because he did he did some
solo stuff later because didn't he do
that song like the never-ending story
like that was the theme of that movie
yeah that dude had a [ __ ] serious
mullet serious Isabella says Ziggy
Stardust
there you go yeah
that worked yeah I think I think I think
I think the guy from cat from from
kajagugu was
copying that kind of I think it's hard
to say yeah I think technically the
spikier mullets look better than like
the fluffy curly mullet yeah what did it
happen does the general rule what
happened in that era
short hair got you're supposed to have
long hair short hair kind of kind of
meant that you that you were lame you
were kind of like military or something
so you weren't supposed to have anything
short
so if you were gonna if you were a rock
star or something that wanted to have
short hair part of it had to be long so
what what part was going to be long it
was me long in the back
so you that way you could have short
hair and long hair at the same time you
could have short hair and not be accused
of having short hair
yeah you can have long hair and have
short hair
yeah you were recovering all your bases
yeah now those that girl [ __ ] had the
perfect mullet to move the [ __ ] white
mullet
till Tuesday you know exactly I was
talking about what was what was the name
of that song that [ __ ] in that video
voice is scary voice is scary that's
right she also had that rat tail had a
rat tail that was also very common in
the 80s like on the in the new wave set
yeah and it actually looked cute on her
it did actually like on some people it
looks stupid as hell but well it's just
kind of like anything like you know not
everything looks good on everybody like
on her that hair looked really good yeah
but I saw some other people that wore it
like that that didn't look it was cut
right yeah it was the right color and
she had the right kind of face for it
and it was just it had been around for a
while and it was a goth mullet basically
yeah a gullet a gullet
as we call it no we don't call it that I
just made that up yeah that voices
voices carry remember a starry night
covered that song yeah like a couple
years back yeah well they took their
their label told them to cover that song
yeah so we gotta have a cover and
it was good it was good I like yeah I
liked their version of it actually it
was pretty good
John Smith says gotta wonder what the
other criminals think of Dennis in jail
do they think he's a bit weird and keep
a distance
no they wouldn't be scared of that dude
well I don't even know not even so much
scared of him as like not wanting to
deal with his [ __ ] he's probably got
some kind of a job in prison
and he walks around with a lot of
self-importance and they probably
probably well respected I'll jump back
working at the library or something
huh oh yeah yeah that's that that's
Dennis Raider oh he's smart you know
that's that's probably he thinks he is
yeah yeah he's he's famous that's
probably how they're going to think
about it yeah maybe he's like an
aspirational figure how [ __ ] up would
that be yeah
those guys are all graded on a curve you
know yeah yeah thank you David June
giving us some monies yeah thanks dude
always love a Dennis Cameo see there you
go you don't do it that much anymore but
like you said you have to be channeling
it yeah I think it helped that you
already drank before yeah
I actually don't like channeling [ __ ]
uh Dennis really yeah no he's not any
fun he's not fun just it doesn't feel
fun to channel that dude because you
could tell he's not fun
well that to me that's what makes it
funny yeah he's not is that he's just
like
yeah but that's what's funny to me he's
a stickler that yeah and that's why I
think you should make fun of him all the
morning stickle a [ __ ]
you know your grass is supposed to be
three and a half this grass
you know right it's not gonna work you
know taking your dog it's a lot more fun
to uh to channel [ __ ] Steve Segal
cigar's a lot more fun the channel I got
to be in the mood for him though you
know and you got to do [ __ ] a cigar
while he's [ __ ] I gotta I like the
channel cigar but he's either pissed or
sexual they want to you know you know
baby
every time I have you here in my pool
all I'm thinking of is Asian experience
baby
you're you're kuchach and my wazir
shit's gone she's gonna be magic
I'm gonna have a drink with me babe
you get down there you get down there in
a pool I'm just gonna stay up here I'm
gonna watch
oh it's beautiful baby
he's like [ __ ] 50 and out of shape
and [ __ ] she's like 20. yeah yeah
she's having like Asian experience yeah
yeah I'm gonna pay all your bills baby
don't you worry
[Laughter]
yeah I don't know uh John Smith says
lamal from kajagugu my ex-boss used to
date him back in the 80s while I say
date I think hooked up a few times which
in the 80s gay scene was a long-term
relationship sure
um Blaster one said Dennis is hated in
jail he's always telling screws [ __ ] and
giving up people oh yeah that sounds
that's that tracks yeah he tries that's
very on brand yeah yeah because he's
going to try to be an authority in there
oh no I'm not a prisoner I'm I'm one of
the guards I'm in charge of you guys I
run this [ __ ] yeah I run this [ __ ] yeah
yeah I'm keeping you guys locked up for
the betterment of the community
we can't let you guys go yeah that
sounds like some [ __ ] you would think
and if I keep you guys locked up they'll
let me out
how old's that [ __ ] now he's got
he's got to be in his 60s now easy
I would have thought he would be older
than like way older than that yeah he's
70s yeah he's probably a rat ratting
people out
yeah like I said that yeah trying to
keep people under control in prison he
have an authority yeah John says Segal
now needs a crane to get in or out of
the pool yeah
yeah they kind of
it's just like one of those crane
machines that Chuck E Cheese's
[Laughter]
Segal needs a body double to sit in the
folding [ __ ] lawn chair on the side
of the pool yeah
I'll tell you is it okay if I need to
get my stunt double in here
yeah you lay here you lay here I'll be
over here we'll just voice it in later
zoom in on my face I'll deliver the line
and then just and then do it from the
back
just shoot him from the back
because you can't lay down now
well he lays down but it looks [ __ ] up
you know what I mean
belly up here look like a walrus laying
there you know and he can't like reach
over to lift up his Margarita yeah yeah
see what happened when when I rolled
over to read to grab the the margarita
when I'm talking about the Asian
experience you can see that I'm I'm not
looking my best I'm looking a little
overweight can we get my son double in
here to roll over and reach for the
margarita just shoot it nobody will know
[Laughter]
he's doing the voiceover for it
he's gonna do the black voiceover all
right it's when when Steven Seagal
talked to somebody black he tries to
become black
hey y'all you know [ __ ] trying to get
super [ __ ] Southern Sound in this
[ __ ]
that's a [ __ ] that would carry
Hot Sauce around his pocket if he's
gonna go hang out with black people
Steven Seagal is just he's from Michigan
and he's Jewish but he's just whatever
ethnic group he's talking to he's a
chameleon
he
is Cajun he's black he's [ __ ]
Japanese he's Chinese I've seen him do
he's I've seen him go Chinese on people
you know that motherfucker's a psycho
only is only a [ __ ] psycho [ __ ]
does that kind of [ __ ]
him [ __ ] they were goofing on him
back in the day on talk shows where you
could tell that talk show host knew that
he was [ __ ] a fraud this is I thought
you grew up in in Japan uh uh yeah no no
no he didn't know he doesn't know
whether to lie or to tell the truth
that's it it's [ __ ] funny
yeah well see that's what happens when
you spend your whole entire life like
making up crazy [ __ ] about yourself you
keep like forgetting like what lie you
sold to weapons yeah
and then once people start comparing
notes then you get in trouble yeah he
didn't go over too well on Saturday
Night Live either evidently they said he
was the worst guest well that was didn't
they ban him from yeah they would love
it or something like that because he was
like the literal word
no because Stan to be rounded well then
I think we talked about that
um we might have talked about that in
our bullshito show yeah where I think
the story was he wanted he was doing
some real [ __ ] up thing like with um
one of the skits they were doing I can't
remember they were kind of poking fun at
him in a skit he didn't want anybody
making fun of him that's part of it yeah
yeah
uh the actor Cliff Curtis has played
nearly every ethnicity on the planet was
he the guy that was on
um Fear The Walking Dead
he's uh he's Maori isn't he that guy
he's been in like a bunch of movies but
I thought that's what he was
yeah Ben said people were uh ragging him
in martial arts magazines for years my
favorite one was when he told everyone
he was a martial arts instructor for the
NYPD and the FBI SWAT teams yeah yeah
yeah like they need they need martial
arts training yeah
well and you know nowadays you can check
obviously but back then I guess they
just kind of people were just yeah I
suppose that it was a different world
back in the day that uh Seagal appeared
it was it was a world of magazines
there was no internet the world of
laughter it was just magazines something
and one of the greatest magazines from
martial arts was [ __ ] black belt and
[ __ ] Black Belt Magazine
I remember reading it as a [ __ ]
teenager up at 7-Eleven where we were
playing [ __ ] video games
like playing rat stand and [ __ ]
Ghouls and ghosts and ghosts and goblins
and [ __ ] garlic and [ __ ] we reach
over there and [ __ ] look at Black
Belt Magazine
and there'd just be all these wild
claims
and we weren't sure what was true or
what was it you know like could was was
throwing cheese ball was that a real
thing we don't know you know it's like a
suit Street Fighter came out and [ __ ]
hit it okay look and do [ __ ] throwing
[ __ ] hurricane balls and [ __ ] they're
maybe something like that was possible
you know we weren't sure
there was no internet debunking
mechanism at that time
I mean we probably would have fallen for
[ __ ] a sheet of Kim in his videos
back in until we saw the video probably
would have bought it though
oh man I got a video coming gonna teach
us all the ways of the [ __ ] Ninja
really yeah and you would have felt like
profoundly ripped off yeah we're gonna
[ __ ] learn the ways of the Ninja
we'll be able to move around nobody will
ever [ __ ] see us all right get the
[ __ ] basically what it tells you is duck
under the windows yeah duck under the
window when you run running a Crouch no
one will see you that kind of [ __ ] is
this man yeah like kind of crawl around
the biggest extent is a sheet of Cam's
[ __ ] knit Ninjutsu was throwing dirt
in a motherfucker's eyes that's dirt
Whoa man that's some magical [ __ ] there
man [ __ ] theatricality just like just
like [ __ ] Batman
[Laughter]
[ __ ] yeah it works man that's right
it works to the uninitiated I am
initiated okay that's what [ __ ] Bane
said I'm initiated it I've been in this
League of Shadows and [ __ ] it's just
funny [ __ ] you know when you think
I mean people will go people will put up
with a lot just because they want to
feel like special
you know what I mean but this is the
mind of 15 year old boys okay and
sometimes that [ __ ] might actually go
into the 20s and 30s depending on how
crazy a [ __ ] is like that damn
fake
fake martial arts master [ __ ] who was
throwing the cheese balls little fat boy
and all those [ __ ] black belt
magazines had were stating that he was
the real thing remember and that and and
the History Channel went in there and
debunked him
um
looking
Gilman no George what's that
motherfucker's name I think it was
Dillman wasn't it Dillman or Tillman or
Tillman or Dillman I can't remember now
his whole Dojo was [ __ ] about
throwing cheese balls
it doesn't work man I wish I had come up
with something that George Tillman I
think
last one says how do you not need
glasses Tom at your age mine started
getting blurry at 40 years old no to
read I do need glasses yeah I can read
without them but it's harder yeah I need
I need glasses to read too not to drive
or anything like that but at the
distance I have my provision's perfect
it's just anything close I have a hard
time seeing yeah I can't really see my
phone or like the screen or something
like that like it's all blurry yeah
I had really good Vision until about how
long ago was it
probably like five years ago
there was one of these I'll tell you
what for a while there was there was
[ __ ] one of these [ __ ] drugs that
I was on
it was a sarm a selective Androgen uh
[ __ ] was a selective Androgen uh
something another modulator
I forgot to say
anyway I forgot what Psalms stood for
it was LD 40 30 and it was just a number
and after about four or five
weeks of that I could see perfectly up
close it corrected my vision
until I stopped taking it and it wore
off it was weird that is pretty weird
yeah I don't know how it how it did it I
guess
it was that particular storm sarm was
supposed to act kind of like a steroid
that was similar to some people compared
it to Dianabol
and it gave you a little bit more it
gave you more muscular strength so I
guess what it was doing is the the
muscles in my eyeballs were able to pull
the leads closer in and get the the
proper Focus for up close but it was
temporary
it only worked while I was on it and the
[ __ ] was expensive and it wasn't
something that you could really live on
for very long so
didn't really
didn't make a permanent change
and it wasn't and it wasn't something
that you would want to be all a long
time ahead it had side effects that were
kind of unpleasant
a lot of testosterone suppression I
could probably be on it now that I was
on
um testosterone replacement therapy
because I take I'm always on test and be
on tests the rest of my life
which means you could I could probably
take LD
but
the cost it would have been worth is
cheaper just to get reading glasses
yeah I mean you can get good reading
glasses yeah reading glass is 20 bucks
and that [ __ ] was like [ __ ] 60 bucks
a month to be on it so it really didn't
didn't really didn't matter yeah
I mean I keep hoping because you know I
don't have insurance or anything like
that so I just keep hoping I said well
I'll just keep buying stronger and
stronger reading glasses until I'm
totally blunt I guess
uh Auntie asked what is your take on the
Idaho student murders I'd have to look
into that because I don't even recall it
yeah I've heard a case I don't think
we've done a show about that and it's
like I've heard of that but I don't
think we've ever done a show about it so
I'll have to get back to you on that
because I don't know the details of it
uh Blaster one said what the [ __ ] you
want Tom you've been a guinea pig for
new drugs he's on all the drugs all the
drugs
um
well
I've been on I've done everything pretty
much no not everything there's a lot of
them I haven't done yet
um nothing I've done has been real it's
exotic
I haven't really the most exotic thing
that I did do were some sarms
but sarms are really uh
the sarms are kind of experimental
but West arms are is a replacement for
steroids but the problem is that
steroids are putting pretty good they're
they're a well understood
um compound and they they understand the
safety parameters they they know
everything pretty much about most of
them it's better to stick with things
that have been around a long time that
you know that they know about than it is
to get involved with [ __ ]
experimental stuff and I think the
reason why they came up with sarms is
because look man [ __ ] drug companies
are corrupt
the patents on steroids had run out so
they can't make any money off those
anymore they have to make up
stuff that's new that's like a steroid
something that they could patent and
then they could full you know con
doctors into prescribing and they'd have
a patent for it they can make a bunch of
money
it's better as a user just to go ahead
and get
well understood steroids that were been
around since the 60s you know
and uh it's a lot safer
and there's a
there was a YouTube video just came out
from some uh science people saying that
everything we know about steroids is
wrong you can look at it on YouTube and
there and this they got a damn
metrosexual dude talking about it yeah
we're kind of wrong about steroid
steroids are really good in anti-aging
Therapies
and they're you know and he talks about
it but you can Google that on they're
not Google that but search that on
YouTube everything we know about
steroids is wrong it's not long about 10
minutes long that video and you'll see
that
in certain applications that's the way
to go
that's what you want to do you can
prolong life
with them on a at the if you use them
the right way in the right doses the
right ones you just can't overdo it you
abuse them that can [ __ ] kill you
but we're not talking about abuse that's
with any drug
you know you abuse any drug it could
kill you
that's true a lot of things can kill you
if you drink too much water it'll kill
you So yeah thank you very much Trey
gave us a super chat Merry Christmas
guys yes Merry Christmas
um I kind of feel like well oh I guess
next week will will be the Christmas
Side Tracks because next week is next
Friday is what the 23rd yeah I'm looking
at the calendar okay because I was
sitting there thinking I don't know what
[ __ ] day it is and I'm just like I
know what day it is but I don't know
what date it is you know what I mean and
so I'm sitting there going is this the
last like Side Tracks for Christmas I
guess not
um I forgot to tell you what tomorrow
at the bar F4 they're going to give out
free prime rib for Christmas party at
what you call if you want to go get it
I've had it before it was good
they were giving out free prime rib they
had a party they gave it can I just take
like a big styrofoam box and like stock
up on it and then bring it back down
you gotta buy some drinks and just eat
pre-front free prime rib
if the food's good there
Ali says uh I love you both but Jenny uh
do you wish that uh Tom would do a
separate program on Fitness Etc
no
it's not I couldn't talk about it that
much
yeah it's kind of like I think the
reason that um that our channel has been
going so long is because we'll just talk
about [ __ ] anything yeah you know
what I mean so we never run out of
topics really it's a from day one when I
started this [ __ ] when we started
this [ __ ] show it was a variety show
basically and the idea was is that we
were kind of like online friends
that was the idea it was it wasn't to
teach you guys anything or to give you
any information or anything like that it
was just
to keep you occupied and so you could
have some online friends you could
listen to We could we kind of just
wanted to talk about cool [ __ ] that we
liked like you know like movies we liked
and like topics we were interested in
and stuff like that and you know what I
mean
heart Jaguar says the name for Tom's new
show is live from the man cave live from
man cave now
if I were to have my own show it would
go down certain directions it would get
boring it would be nothing but a sausage
fest anyway but just guys
that's what ended up happening sorry I
was I had another I had another funny
funny like mental image of like the
little thing with like all these little
dicks
[Laughter]
that was an animated that was an
animated movie wasn't it sausage party
we probably I kind of want to see that
actually probably be talking about
military equipment stuff just the
minutia of [ __ ] military yeah he
would nerd out about that yeah I mean I
can't really like say because I you know
I do my re on like book reviews and my
movie reviews and I nerd out about like
horror movies yeah so it's kind of like
the same nerding out over [ __ ] Poncho
liners and how how long when was the
Poncho lighter invented and [ __ ] how
many bungee cord it should go with it
and [ __ ] and the the it would be the
years it would it would be it would it
would be very specialty all right it
wouldn't be any good though
John Smith said I found you all due to
Jenny's review of House of leaves well
[ __ ] man
I can't I've been wanting to like read I
don't know I just feel like I feel like
I did that review and I've been wanting
to do it for such a long time because
that was a book that I wanted to read it
and then like I always feel like I
didn't like cover everything I wanted to
cover I get like really weird like that
Ali also asked how is Pookie she's doing
good she was she was here just a minute
ago she sometimes you'll sometimes see
her like her little Stumpy tail run
around in the back you know what I mean
she likes to like run around about on
the in the background
[Music]
um
oh and remember the other day when I
said I got my YouTube like year in
review that said like what the most
watched videos were and stuff and I said
oh I couldn't remember what the first
what the most watched one was this year
but I remember the second one which was
like the herb almeister Fox Hollow Farm
one and I was like huh random
um I remembered what the first one was
the top one was my review of threads
that British
um nuclear war movie from the 80s do you
know how we had the day after do you
remember that movie from like 1983 or
whatever it was that's lit positive it's
fictional but it posited like what would
happen if there was like if the ruskies
like blew us up or whatever
um with nuclear bombs well the British
had one too but of course because it was
British it was like way way more
realistic and Bleaker and uh it's pretty
much a horror movie even though it's
like really realistic so that's for
whatever reason that was our that was
the Channel's top watched video
in this past year why I don't know but
that's what it was
um Kalyn Higgins said have you thought
about reviewing the Thomas Harris
Hannibal collection as in the books or
the movies
um
I maybe could I've actually read Mo I've
read
um
well I read Silence of the Lambs for
sure I read Hannibal
did I read Manhunter or like the one
that
Red Dragon
that's what uh Hannibal was based on
right red dragon I can't remember now
I've read most of them but it's been
like such a long time I'd have to like
sit down and watch or read them like all
again
young Hannibal is the other one Leanne
says hello all my first time here well
hey welcome to this
Asylum of
of craziness
yeah right yeah oh okay I thought you
look kind of spaced out for a minute
because you stopped talking yeah let me
go put some more ice in this John Smith
said threads is a bleak as Hell movie it
really is I mean
I'd been hearing about it for such a
long time and I was really excited that
shutter added it and I was like one of
these days I got to sit down and like
watch this kind of [ __ ] and I was like
well now I'm depressed
but you know
yeah red dragon was the first novel to
feature Harris's character Dr Lecter
yeah I remember
I remember reading that
I don't even think we've reviewed the
movie Man Hunter like the and I've been
wanting to do that one too I think I
remember I put it in the poll a couple
times but it didn't win
so one of these days
one of these days I don't think I have
red dragon I do like the book I have
Silence of the Lambs in here somewhere
and I have
Hannibal in here somewhere
got him
no I'm talking about the book yeah I
just but I don't have red dragon look I
don't think
Cheryl says the Joe Bob Christmas
special is on shutter tonight at 9pm ooh
his Christmas specials are always good
well his Halloween specials are good too
but I didn't see the Halloween massager
but they're still there like you can see
them after
I like his I particularly liked the one
that he did with Jack Frost on it the
one with the Killer Snowman that movie's
[ __ ] hilarious
I watched it again the other day like
the rift tracks one
because it made me laugh so much what
are you two drinking uh joined late
Vodka it's vodka and lemonade yeah
what's up poop
I'm drinking tequila before this
oh there's Pokey yeah big old fat
pumpkin
she's not fashion she's getting fat yeah
you're getting fat she's like shopping
you're like a big old fat look at her
look at her little her face she told her
he called her a little turkey well yeah
they've been calling her a turkey
regularly you're like a little turkey
you know that she's like screamed
[Laughter]
you grab her at the shoulders and then
you go down to the belly and it gets big
yeah yeah
you fat little pumpkin
yeah he's getting fat
she doesn't go anywhere
just runs around the house and funny
because she she runs wide open her belly
be swinging from the right left you can
see her when you see her go the belly's
focused away it's [ __ ] funny well
she's like I said she's a Manx and they
kind of have that little body type they
have a pot belly anyway they have a
little pot belly like a little pouch and
they have like really short legs yeah so
she's very round yeah but she is very
funny like the way because she has those
little bitty legs and she kind of has
this little this little run that she
does and her little belly just goes like
that was she runs super funny I feel
like she doesn't eat the cocoa
excessively I don't think Coco the
gorilla she had a Manx and she called it
all ball yeah which that makes perfect
sense when you see when everything is
round the head's round the body's round
everything's round on them yeah so yeah
she's just around with a little short
legs and when she lays on her back yeah
it's round because a lot of times She
lays on her back like and she looks like
she looks exactly like a Gummy Bear yeah
like with her little paws up like that
she looks exactly like a gummy bear with
like a little round pill yeah she's
ridiculous
she is she is a little very expressive
face you could she should give you these
Expressions you know like [ __ ] angry
or [ __ ] funny or just you know her
little her mad face like makes me laugh
so much like you do something or you say
something she doesn't like she gives you
that little [ __ ] I'm like uh oh she's
giving me little mad face yeah
you suck
Pookie's wasting away
you can play your ribs like this
xylophone no she's not wasting away
she's thick yeah yeah I don't like I
said I don't think she eats excessively
she doesn't eat the Chanel she loves the
Sheba meat sticks though yeah I Gotta
Buy like a big pack of those like every
three weeks or something because she
Chows down through those things
Cheryl says she's not fat she's just
curvy yeah or fluffy she's
uh what are Pookie's favorite treats
these days
she likes um she's the meat sticks to
the tuna ones the tuna ones like yeah I
have to get those like by the it's not a
case but it's like a big box that has
like a whole bunch of pouches any
Temptations flavor yeah she'll eat
pretty much any of those I don't even
think she has favorites anymore she
likes the red ones like those ones over
there which is called backyard cookout
which is like chicken liver and beef
yeah and she likes the chicken ones she
likes them all I got the ones that are
pink that are I think it's called
shrimpy shrimp or something she likes
those she likes anything like shrimpy
yeah or tuna the weird thing about it
and I said this the other day like she
likes those Shiba meat sticks and she
loves the tuna ones the tuna ones are
her favorite she'll eat the chicken ones
but she's kind of meh about it but she
does not like the salmon ones like
she'll eat them but really really
grudgingly yeah like if you the meat
sticks she doesn't like salmon like if
you give her the salmon when she kind of
like yeah she's like yeah this is right
and then she'll kind of lick it and be
like okay she's like nah
but she likes a chicken once a little
she'll eat them but the tuna meat sticks
that's the one she really likes oh my
God she loves it yeah
somebody sent us like an off brand of
the chicken meat sticks and and she eats
those
remember somebody yeah like a different
somebody says it wasn't it was well I
don't know another one it's just a
yellow bag those might have come with
because remember I ordered some like
emergency yeah Sheba ones on chewy yeah
and it came like in a mixed
uh set like with those ones I can't
remember what brand it was but I was
like I was like oh she probably won't
eat those but she liked those channels
she liked those too but for some reason
those tuna meat sticks and they really
they stink too she loves like really
stinky like fishy stinkier it is the
more she likes it but you would think
that she would like salmon because
Salmon's pretty stinky yeah see that's
what but she doesn't like the salmon
ones for whatever reason um about the
way they taste she's like yeah I don't
know what it is
El padrino said I called out some
[ __ ] that cut me off right after work
turned out to be one of my supervisors
well you know you shouldn't be driving
like that so
and let me see
Ben says my cat jockser adores
freeze-dried raw lamb hearts
I don't think we've ever given her those
for a while we had those little remember
we had the bags of like little dried
fishies
like weren't they little yeah
yeah she didn't eat some of them and
then she's look at you like uh we're
probably supposed to eat that this is
not using it I don't think I'm supposed
to eat that yeah yeah she's been guilty
like it's like I don't know how I feel
about this yeah she's like I don't know
and she's not you had to sneak him you
had to sneak him to her one out you know
little by little
little dried fish faces on him and [ __ ]
maybe that's what freaked her out she's
like I don't really like she did it and
then she'd look at you like
I'm not sure that was right
it's okay
that she'd walk away from him sometimes
she'd only eat one at a time
you had to like spring them on her
if you left three of them out she'd
never eat them yeah yeah
Leanne said is the kitty black or gray I
couldn't see she's gray yeah she's gray
and she has
um a very very faint kind of like stripy
pattern but it's kind of hard to see it
see him you know what I mean
and she we were saying the other day but
she really does not like because I know
like some cats like people food and
they'll just come and like steal food
off your plate and [ __ ] like that not
her she's not into it she likes whipped
cream yeah like if you're eating
something with whipped cream on it like
a piece of pie or something she'll come
over and like want to stick her nose in
that she'll get up and [ __ ]
smell what you're eating yeah like look
at it she might look lick it once cause
I'll let her lick it
because I know she won't eat it she'll
walk away she's like nah she'll she'll
lick it and then she'll look at you like
damn
how are you eating what is your only
thing the only thing that I thought she
was actually gonna finish was I was
eating a Nutter butter A Little Debbie's
Nutter butter and cheese Nutty Buddy
and I [ __ ] like which is like a wafer
it's like it's like a KitKat with peanut
butter chocolate
bigger though
I'm sorry she she wanted to know what it
was so I put it down there so she could
get some she's smelling it and then she
licked some and it broke off
it fell on the floor and she licked it
and licked it and licked it and licked
it and then walked away from it
and I went to go grab it pick it up
throw it away and it was just like mushy
because I had all that [ __ ] cat spit
in it she was spitting on it but she
never did that
I thought she was gonna eat it though
because she heard me crunching it
so it must be good because yeah her
treats crunch yeah she likes crunchy
stuff yeah if it's crunchy it must be
good
it's crazy funny cat and we always kind
of laugh at her too because we put like
some little treats like on this little
dish and she she sometimes eats him on
the plate but normally she likes to take
she takes her little paw and like
slides it off onto the carpet she eats
it on the carpet and then eats it on the
carpet only one at a time yeah she's
very dainty yeah
pushes them off one at a time and then
she's like she's [ __ ] crazy
everything she does is like [ __ ]
hilarious
Tammy says some cats have a primordial
uh pouch like a flabby belly it doesn't
matter the sex or breed scientists don't
know why yeah I had heard that
that
um that's why I keep telling you don't
give her a complex by like time yes she
does she does not understand what I'm
saying yes she does I'm telling you she
does
because I've said like something before
like you know if I said something like
teasing her before and then she looks at
me like don't you make fun of me [ __ ]
she gives me a face like that yeah I
think she knows what I'm saying
John Smith said I think one of my cats
is The Reincarnation of Jeffrey Dahmer
he prefers his food live and then plays
with the bodies
no she killed she would kill lizards but
she didn't need him
yeah she didn't now I used to have a cat
that would eat the lizards except for
the head she would always just leave
lizard heads everywhere like out on the
porch the old house she came running up
to with something in her mouth I looked
at it was a dead gopher I don't think
she killed it but she was trying to
claim that she killed it yeah she she
brought me the dead gopher and reared up
on her back legs and she had it in her
mouth with her [ __ ] hands on the dead
gopher and body slammed it twice
look look look this is Pookie WWE yeah
body slammed it it's like damn
then she looked at me and said look I
got it I said you did not kill that
she was trying to claim and she killed
that she's like oh I just found this
dead thing baby killed it I don't know
yeah she found it because didn't we find
I think beige I think Beijing killed it
that's what I'm saying yeah because
didn't we find like at the poor on the
porch at the old house didn't we find a
squirrel with no head or something like
did somebody like pulled the squirrel's
head off yeah I think it was a squirrel
some [ __ ] like that that was Beijing
yeah Beijing did that
I don't know if does Beijing kill
anything anymore I haven't found any
dead stuff out on the porch not recently
not recently I think she just kind of
likes to
sit and watch now she'll bring a dead
bird she brought a bird into the house
it was live remember that
yeah yeah now let the bird go
well Pookie used to bring in when she
used to go out on the porch at the old
house like she would bring in lizards
all the time yeah she just I think she
just brought him in because she wanted
something to play with she didn't like
want to eat them or nothing
but she outgrew that she doesn't care
about him anymore not really
all right so
how long we've been doing this show
about an hour probably
yeah 56 minutes all right so Now's the
Time for you guys to go ahead and ask
questions if you guys want to talk about
any cases from the past
or well don't say that because I might
not remember that yeah
[Laughter]
we were watching that Graham Hancock
Series yeah I was going to wonder where
you're gonna bring that up and uh it's a
good series ancient apocalypse it's on
Netflix it's on Netflix
so we're probably in like episode four
by now five maybe yeah what did I
thought we watched
four and five last night or something
it's a good series even though um
I think I think Hancock has got some
[ __ ] backwards
he has a theory that mankind survived
this ancient apocalypse so he goes out
and looks for things
to to fulfill that
that concept that narrative
and that's not really how you're
supposed to do it
um I think I think he's right about
certain things I think there are very
ancient societies
maybe around the Ice Age
he is not saying that they were
industrial I think they were
pre-industrial and he's basically saying
the same thing
but that doesn't mean
his claims are correct
you know
like I don't think that [ __ ]
thing at the [ __ ] around Bimini is a
road the Bimini Road I don't think
that's the structure I don't think so
either I think that's a natural I think
that's a natural thing some of the other
stuff that he showed
his old sites I think they were sites
and they're real old but I don't think
they have anything to do with the an
ancient apocalypse
because
the beginnings and the ends of ice ages
take a long time the people that are
living through those don't notice
anything unusual
so there isn't he has this big thing but
well they've passed down this knowledge
they're trying to send us a message and
no
those people were just
building structures and farming and
keeping track of the Stars so they knew
when it was to plant and
follow doing their little religious
rights and yeah I don't really kind of I
mean people I think even people nowadays
mostly just kind of concentrate on you
know their own lifetimes maybe their
kids lifetimes you know you're just kind
of like trying to live your life you're
not really worried about what's going to
happen a thousand years from now or
anything like that and I don't think
people back then were either I think
that's just our bias talking because
it's like we're we live thousands of
years later so we're like oh well they
must have been like trying to send us a
message yeah I was like no they weren't
no they were just kind of just living
the day today living in day to day like
most people do nowadays right
and um then he kind of he's kind of
coming up with this other theory that
all of the civilizations were related to
one another and that they remembered
some original core civilization that
they split off from
you know like they all had pyramids and
that they all they all [ __ ] uh had
stories about the same kind of gods and
that they all were watching the same
group of stars
that's not what that means man yeah
everyone was related to one another
everyone's kind of cousins
the humans are pretty similar you know
they're gonna in the night sky they're
gonna pick out the brightest stars just
like you would yeah and they're gonna
pick out the stars that seem to be in
certain places at certain times that are
notified that that are noteworthy you
know like the dog star and you know
[ __ ]
and they're gonna yeah they're gonna
build pyramids because a pyramid is like
a mountain but it's got four sides well
that's
that's the minimum amount of size you
can do three sides but it'd probably be
harder to do three sides makes more
sense to do four sides
five sides on a pyramid would be harder
so what we just do four so people tend
to gravitate towards the same kind of
tropes and Concepts no matter where you
are so
you know
yeah I mean like I said humans are
similar in the world over so when
presented with the same set of
circumstances they're going to come up
with similar solutions to problems right
they probably don't look exactly the
same as cultural differences but you
know in the aggregate they're they tend
to be pretty similar if you're a man
and you believe in a god
you're going to say that that God's a
man
so if the God's a man he's got a wife
because you got a wife yeah he's got a
wife
and guess what
you got children so that God must have
children too she's going to have stories
so all the stories are like that yeah
it's just like you know the way it is
it's just like the way stuff is but like
exalted yeah you know right and it's not
because they all descended from the same
civilization it's because people are
real similar the way they think yeah
it's those same tropes over and over
again yeah I don't think yeah I don't
think you necessarily have to pause
because I kind of feel like what he's
trying to get at is that you know this
because he keeps bringing up stories
about like how a lot of cultures have a
story about like a person that came and
like taught like brought people
technology you know like the
Quetzalcoatl and all that kind of stuff
and I'm just kind of like
um I don't know I just I don't think
it's necessary to posit that like that
you had to have one person that came and
like hey I'm from the smarter City over
there like hey dummies I'm gonna show
you how to like build this that and the
other thing or show you how to like Farm
or whatnot we'll look at it this way
if you were to make up a story how you
learned things today and you're a kid
or let's say you're a young civilization
in your room at night you're gonna say
yeah the internet
I heard it on the internet the internet
is what taught me how to [ __ ] build
my civilization you know they didn't
have internet back then the closest
thing to an internet back then was a
dude that came from somewhere else
this dude came in here and he [ __ ]
showed us this cool [ __ ] you know it's
kind of like an email of the day yeah
that's all it is dude came over here and
uh he showed us this stuff then he went
back
he went back to where we came from
that's just that would just be The
Logical way of just of explaining how
you learned something man came it showed
us
because I kind of feel
those those stories like pass around
because usually knowledge like that is
incremental right it's like you just
kind of like learn it over generations
and generations and like you kind of
perfect things yeah and so but it's easy
like in story forms like you said to
just say oh there was this really wise
man that came down from the mountain or
whatever and like told us how to do all
this [ __ ] like whoever a thousand years
ago yeah and whoever's writing this
wasn't there right you know what I mean
the civilization's already formed if
somebody says how'd this all start
oh well long time ago dude came and
showed us
because that's how things happened back
then
you know if he if he said no long time
ago we got an email
you gotta download okay I'd really be
impressed but that's not what you're
saying they're just saying dude came
showed us the name way back where he
came from because that's the way things
happened back then yeah it was real real
that was the level of technology that
they were at so there's just a lot of
stuff like that in Grand Graham Hancock
I'm not gonna say he's full of [ __ ]
it's just um
he's got a narrative to sell
yeah
uh I do believe you should question
uh archeology question everything that's
what science is about it's being
skeptical and questioning and checking
and double checking
but some of the stuff he's positing is
unlikely you know there are other
explanations for what he's talking about
yeah a lot of his stuff is really a
reach yeah it's a good reach like I'm
not really the only thing that I think
that I agree with him on is that oh well
you know a lot of the sites that they
found like are much older and they think
than they think they were and so like
people had like technology like you know
many thousands of years before we
previously thought there there's nothing
crazy about that that's you know that's
fine and there is actually evidence for
that but like some of the other stuff
that he comes up with is really a reach
Richard Brown too said uh Hancock wrote
a book about the face on Mars yeah the
face on Mars that this is a hill which
is not a face it's not there that hill
on Mars it doesn't even look look like a
faith yeah
it's a hill
the face is only because the technology
that they had at the time you look at a
clearer picture of it there's nothing
there
but uh yeah he's just uh he's positing
stuff that's
unlikely
it's just more likely that although I do
agree with him
uh humans were doing agriculture for a
long time further back than than they
thought
uh some of that stuff like gobekly tappy
some of that [ __ ] goes back into the Ice
Age probably you find it and he says
well [ __ ] they must have been this just
10 000 years old and they probably were
here for 2 000 years doing this because
there's a lot more of that stuff there
in that area yeah because there's like
they wait they did ground penetrating
radar and there's like a bunch more yeah
like little Chambers and stuff right
under the hill and when you start
getting into the damn Ice Age
the the sea levels were a lot lower
and people especially in the
pre-industrial era tended to live on the
Coastland it's easier to live on the
coast
because you can fish and there's just
better resources
so chances are all the real old stuff is
underneath the ocean now you'd never
find it
and that's a problem with all this
ancient Lost Civilization stuff
I'm sure there are ancient lost
civilizations but hell yeah there are
they're underneath the ocean though now
probably they would have been on the
coast
and I don't think there's a
there was so much time and even before
the Ice Age
something could have been industrial but
but for a while and every bit of that
would be gone
somebody would say well 30 000 years ago
there was no there's no evidence of any
of that
if this civilization were to end
and thirty thousand years were to pass
there wouldn't be a trace of this
civilization thirty thousand years from
now it would all be gone yeah that's a
long bucket the structures that we build
are just not meant to last that long
nowhere near as long as say the Great
Pyramid
and all the little pollutions and [ __ ]
would all be gone we would just 30 000
years from now those people would think
that the whatever pollution we left
behind they'd think that was normal
you know it was just oh yeah that's the
normal [ __ ] stuff that's in the
atmosphere they just wouldn't
nothing we're going to do it's going to
stay around for very long
the longest the longest thing you're
going to have the last or the the most
long lasting object we'll ever make was
probably those great pyramids in Giza
those are going to take a long time to
erode away
and that
and that Sphinx is probably much older
than the than those great pyramids
yeah that's uh that's the theory isn't
it yeah well even so I mean even think
well when they were talking about um
thank you very much El padrino uh Super
Chat payday I'll try to do better next
payday oh thank you very much that's
really really nice we need we need uh
patrons too please join our patreon
account
even if it's only five dollars a month
it would make a big difference right
like I said even a dollar even a dollar
a month on patreon would make a
difference for us I mean anything like
that would be
good
um what was I gonna say uh yeah and like
even the pyramids well when he was doing
the show about Gobekli Tempe which
that's even like way way older than the
pyramids and even that is well I was
gonna say it's only it's only like 10
600 or 11 000 years old or something
like that and they were in that area
probably for at least two thousand years
doing that so I mean 30 000 years that's
like three times longer than that [ __ ]
has been there and that's like the
oldest [ __ ] they've found so far like
anything of that magnitude thank you
very much Zach hope y'all are doing good
we are we are what's up Zach
Zach contacted me about relationship
problems I'm giving him giving him
advice on how to deal with his men
oh are you giving any advice on how to
deal with this man it's gonna be all
right Zach don't worry about it
what's your advice on dealing with men
Tom
well I don't want to give up all of his
[ __ ] well you don't have to do that
you can just like you can just give
generalizations I'm just curious um
well my advice all all it all fits it's
all a response to what whatever the
situation you know and the information I
can give it okay he showed me some
letters and I was going and I said okay
this is what you need to do so I gave
him my advice okay so it wasn't like a
general account no I wasn't sure okay
that's fine yeah don't get in this
position
foreign
loves you Zach you need to commit [ __ ]
come here
Zach says uh I don't care Tom can tell
the story I need opinions
but then also grampers asked uh where's
the best place to put Optics on an AR
build
a hoop Graham yeah
uh well it depends on what kind of optic
it is if you talk about a red dot you
want that flush with the upper receiver
before it gets to the rail
and uh that's that's where most
militaries will put it
that'll leave you plenty of uh room in
the back for magnifiers if you're gonna
put magnifiers or backup
mechanical sites
um I'm kind of a firm believer that
all right there's a dip there's a couple
different ways couple different ways to
think about military rifles today
high tech [ __ ]
and what's been going on the past
[ __ ] five or ten years it actually
kind of Falls more into kind of like
heavy duty law enforcement that's with
Optics
but the traditional [ __ ] is iron sights
all right I love Iron Sights and if you
want [ __ ] iron sights you go with the
old A1 and A2 setups and the old [ __ ]
AK setups just nice mechanical sights
you don't need batteries it doesn't
matter what the temperature is it can be
40 degrees below zero that [ __ ] works
and it'll work for your [ __ ] longer
than you will live in combat those
[ __ ] iron sights will work in our
sights have when used properly
both eyes open and just [ __ ] painting
the target with a [ __ ] front sight on
it you can get a lot of the same effects
that you would get
from
Optics and you have to remember that in
a military application we're using
tracers so tracers help and now
tracer-like projectiles are now
available
for civilian sales
and that was our version of the red dots
as [ __ ] tracers okay
if you're going to use Red Dot
if you're going to have red dot you
probably don't need to you don't need
the iron sights
just run Red Dot used to be I saw guys
they were running both Red Dot and
[ __ ] irons
that's redundant they say well if the
Red Dot fails you will have backups and
the chances of that failing within the
mission parameters is [ __ ] Slim
run one or the other
I like ultra light beer builds like what
would Stoner do 2020 type rifles
with [ __ ] Red Dot
for internal security If You're Gonna Go
real hardcore survivalist higher sites
as light as possible pencil Barrel
that was a stoner's original concept
five pal rifle or below that's what I
like I don't like putting all that
[ __ ] on there
oh you know even my [ __ ] ultralight
and I do have ultralight builds with red
dots I'm still running M4 style [ __ ]
lights on the side with [ __ ] strobes
you don't need [ __ ] IR laser or any
other [ __ ] you don't need any of that
and that's just all you need for
internal security everything has to be
light and simple
if it had if you need robustness and
survivability you go strip it all down
and just go with iron sights okay I'm
done
Louie says the last ice age was ended
about a thousand years ago supposedly
humans were all hunter gatherers I doubt
that
um but there are some places older than
that like go beckley's happy yeah that's
kind of what he was talking about right
um I yeah I'm just kind of saying that
it's like I don't think it's crazy to
posit that yeah like some of the
population of the world might have been
Hunter guys I don't think that but I
don't think all of them were because
just like you know everybody nowadays is
like at different levels of like yeah
technology well not so much you still
got tribal Bushman now yeah in certain
places right I think in during the Ice
Age you had it was like the Conan days I
think you had city-states back in the
code
[Laughter]
you would have had city states
which were tribal city-states and they
were they were doing agriculture along
the Equator
then you had mobile tribesmen hunting
hunting woolly mammoth and bison and
stuff like that up in the ice you know
during certain parts of the Season you
would have had both simultaneously I
think
um but you can find stuff that's very
old
that is high tech
uh the arrow is very high tech even the
adult is high tech I challenge you to
make an arrow
from nothing
you need tools to make an arrow and you
need glues you know you need glue to
make compound bows
so a lot of these things that people
think are primitive are actually real
hard to make I challenge you to make
yeah they had to make all that [ __ ] from
just like stuff they found like in the
woods or whatever right so you can just
go down to [ __ ] Radio Shack yeah they
pick [ __ ] up you know yeah you know it's
just it's just kind of a Yankee white
boy kind of thinking oh my God the
Primitive Arrow a challenge wasn't able
to make a [ __ ] Arrow
Lakota can make an arrow all right and
it would the the them to to make an
arrow you had well all not just the
Lakota all the Native Americans can make
arrows you have to understand the basics
of aerodynamics how to make [ __ ] a
glue how to tie how to make thread and
how to tie a [ __ ] um veins onto the
end of The Arrow they have to be set the
right way so you can get some spin they
have to be the right length things have
to be balanced properly even the weights
of things had have to be correct or that
Arrow will not yeah they had to have
they had to understand physics they
understand this [ __ ] this is an advanced
problem versus like making a rocket okay
yeah dumb people couldn't do this well
they said well that wasn't long ago that
was the 1800s or 1700s that [ __ ]
European dude Frozen on top of that
mountain that was almost 10 000 years
ago I think it was he had an arrow that
was as good as a Native American from
the 1800s
utsi and he's Frozen I think that was
what 15th out 10 15 000 years ago
remember how old it would say was
actually so
and he was also tattooed he was he was
tattooed up and stuff a little bitty guy
up here up in the Swiss Alps and um
and he had another an advanced
understanding of aerodynamics basically
to make an arrow
and I challenge you working in your
[ __ ] office with your laptop to make
that arrow with nothing
with no tools just let you loosen the
yeah just go out in the yard
you couldn't do it and find some [ __ ]
and make it there so you're not dealing
with dummies those dudes were very smart
it people think it was a long time ago
they must have been dumb no not at all
well yeah I mean in a lot of ways it's
it's just like you know necessity is the
mother of invention you you needed to
make things to you know kill animals for
food do things like that so you had to
figure it out
you had to figure out the problem yeah
or you were in big trouble so well they
knew how to make bronze and they were
making Sharp Tools and Tanning hides and
leathers and all that shit's Advanced
that's Advanced thinking it's not that
far from Industrial Revolution
the Industrial Revolution happens when
you have a population density that's
high enough to have the trading routes
that you need for all that [ __ ] to
happen that's the only difference
if you spoke the same language and you
were from the 1800s you could talk to
Utz and you wouldn't be that far removed
from one another
yeah probably not to be honest because
like I said it's really only since the
Industrial Revolution that technology
has really because we were talking about
this last night we were watching The
Graham Hancock show I was like the thing
about it was that it's really only in
the last
you know 50 100 years that technology
has been like exponentially yeah growing
the way that it has like up till then
like technology still progressed but it
was like much slower obviously so I
don't think people would have noticed as
much difference in their lifetimes as
people do nowadays I mean because just
look at our life I mean you know I'm 50
years old but you know when I was born
like we didn't have any of this [ __ ]
like you know what I mean we didn't have
like we didn't have cell phones we don't
have the internet we didn't have any of
the [ __ ] that we have now pretty much
um you know it wasn't that [ __ ] we
still had phones and stuff obviously but
it was a lot different
you know and then just like a few
decades before that they didn't have
like TVs or nothing so another thing was
just back then and this is even in in in
the times of just the Native Americans
here in the U.S with the white man
watching them and cataloging what they
would do
they probably would have been about the
on par with utsi and they were still
very physically competent okay Lakota
could ride a horse at full gallop
throw themselves underneath the neck of
the horse while they were riding and
fire a bow from underneath the neck of
the horse undercover and hit another man
on a horse when they were both a full
gallop
at a distance you know
that's a [ __ ] very good physical
prowess you know and they made all that
stuff and they could train horses the
horses weren't indigenous to the new
world but they adapted and they adapted
to him quickly they only came here in
the 1500s 1400s the Native Americans
adapted to them quickly and learned to
raise them and train them and ride them
okay so you're not talking about
ecstatic people
let's see when everything would have
been the same way this is the way humans
were humans are smart no matter what you
give them
you know and uh nowadays you got enough
technology to Shield people from all
these problems you have people that
normally would have been would have died
they're still alive
okay
people that normally weren't physically
didn't have the physical promise they're
still alive and when normally they in in
the wild they would have died by now so
if you were to go back in time and
you're [ __ ] Back to the Future
[ __ ] DeLorean
you're going to run across these people
you would think well those primitive
Savages and guess what they're probably
better than you are at getting the [ __ ]
done
uh they may not understand what
electricity is or what a laptop is
but when it comes to getting food and
riding horses and jumping on things and
fighting and uh turning an animal into
usable products and making a [ __ ]
hide into [ __ ] clothing and how to
stay warm and dry and live comfortably
in the field no they were good at that
real good you know and they just grew up
like that and
they were tough that was just what you
did that's what you did you had to do
that it wasn't like there was an option
right but they were also thinking about
things and they had stories to explain
things and you know humans are creative
only creative people can survive
that kind of condition
and creativity flexibility yeah and and
they enjoyed their their standard of
their way of life
the Indians really the American Indians
were fighting to protect their lifestyle
more than anything else you know the
white man didn't really defeat them what
defeated them or the locomotive the
Telegraph and and and private land
ownership fences
because once you had that there's no you
couldn't chase the Buffalo anymore
and a lot of Indians just said [ __ ] it
and got jobs and as soon as you start
getting jobs and going into town you're
going to start marrying people that
weren't Indians and you start to
gravitate away from that and World War
II was pretty much the end of the of the
Indian Reservation lifestyle
those guys went off to World War II and
they didn't want to go back to the
reservation they're now just they want
to go [ __ ] move to L.A you know
and they married white women and stuff
and that was just because
Indians and white people intermarried
going back for 1500 back in the 1500s
yeah
they call it racial ad mixture
a lot of unions just got absorbed over
time
Zach says speaking of ancient stuff on
the Nevada Utah border there's a super
volcano Caldera about 30 million years
old that vomited they think 5 900 uh
what is that kilometer that's not
kilometers whatever of tephra largest
eruption ever on the planet that's kind
of what um
on the Graham Hancock show last night
when he was talking about oh there must
have been like some big cataclysm and
the way that he was talking about it if
indeed it did happen at the time that he
said it happened it sounded like a super
volcano explosion to me but yeah me and
Jim were talking about that when that
happened a lot of that [ __ ] they're
talking about the great that's this this
big
catastrophic we haven't got we were
evidently the show he gets more into it
as the episodes go oh yeah it's building
up it's building up it's like in
chapters
so far what what he's saying me and
Jenny pretty much on top is that he must
have been either a super volcano that's
what it sounds like to me or some kind
of asteroid impact yeah that's my that
was being my second choice right which
is which plausible very [ __ ]
plausible well yeah it's happened before
before both of those things have
happened before you can have a damn
super volcano so bad it just brings on a
damn Ice Age
well there was that really bad one in
1816 1815 whenever that was and then it
caused like really really bad like uh
craps and like you know remember because
1816 was like The Year Without a summer
all that kind of stuff because of that
volcano going off and like blocking out
the Sun for a couple of years the thing
is is people think they pictured this in
a weird way you could have a super
volcano
you might have several bad winners
but you wouldn't die you wouldn't be
chances are it wouldn't impact you as
much as you would think
the problems would would happen over
centuries
you know
over a couple hundred years certain
species would go extinct uh cities would
have gotten slowly smaller the human
population would have been smaller but
in each one of your lifetimes or these
people they wouldn't really notice it it
would just seem normal
yeah because I mean if you really only
live 50 60 70 80 years you don't notice
it it's it's yeah it's that's not really
a long time in the grand scheme of
things yeah so
it's not like one day there it's
everything's normal and then the volcano
happens and then that's the end of the
world and oh you suck and oh man [ __ ]
it's not like that it wasn't even like
that for the dinosaurs
they had that big asteroid impact yeah I
mean that was probably really scary when
that happened like that day that it
happened but but most of them survived
it yeah it took a long time for him to
die from the from the repercussions of
that
yeah I mean other than the ones that
were right there like you know right
near where the impact site was
because they they survived it and they
tried to make a living the way they
always did whatever kind of animal it
was
but it was harder now
you could make a living it's just that
the bar got raised
some more of you died each year you know
than normal
so slowly they just dwindled
because the conditions had changed
but if you wouldn't have noticed it
within a lifetime of a dinosaur
yeah and that's the thing too I kind of
feel like sometimes like I said because
people have
you know we we see things in terms of
our own lifespan which isn't really all
that long and so when I I just remember
hearing that some people saying stuff
like oh you know people
walked over to North America for example
like during the last ice age and people
like oh they just walked I'm like they
didn't walk over here in one day like
from continent to continent but it's
like if they only walked like a couple
miles a day then eventually you know
over
not even that long really like you know
just over a few decades or a few
centuries or something like that it
doesn't really take that long if it's
just like a little bit at a time but
people aren't really used to
I don't know I I and I guess too because
like when you read history like just by
necessity they have to sort of truncate
everything and put it into like a you
know a narrative type of story so the
way that it's told it really does kind
of sound like oh everything happened
like
quickly or everything happened in one
day when really it might have taken like
centuries or Millennia or something like
that so it wasn't like you just woke up
one day and like everything was
different you might not have even
noticed any change really which is very
incremental yeah
you know Louie's saying he thought the
the best episodes were the were the ones
about Mexico but he's biased yeah yeah
well you know the uh the meshika never
really got the uh the credit that was
due them you know what I mean Egypt was
always stealing the Limelight
but uh according to the Dominican Friars
who went through all that
um Mesoamerican stuff you know that the
Aztecs had said that they're
that their um libraries
were every bit as advanced it's like
ancient Roman and Greek libraries they
they would be they had orders
by the Vatican to destroy all that stuff
and they were like nah we can't really
destroy this this is this isn't really
the right thing to do the the Friars
that were there on the ground were like
going nah
you can't do this this is like on par
with like you know the Greek poetry and
[ __ ] you know what I mean but eventually
they got they got forced into [ __ ]
burn and all that stuff
the the church
believed that
that library and the sum of the Mayan
knowledge and Aztec knowledge was uh
supporting
a religion that uh promoted child
sacrifice
and uh you know [ __ ] so that it had
to go
I kind of agreed with the with the with
the with the monks the monks said that
now we should pick through this you know
what I mean don't yeah baby right it's
really never the best idea right and
especially like I said if it's just a
book even if it has like shitty ideas in
it like I don't even Advocate you know
burning copies of Minecon for anything
like this don't do that it's like you
know any kind of information yeah yeah
it's valuable right you need a record of
that like I don't I don't really ever
think it's a good idea to destroy things
like that you know even if the idea is
in it or Monster the monks are well the
monks are saying that a lot of this
wasn't religious it was just poetry
right it was poetry and things about
Mathematics and Technology
but they were being told by the Vatican
to destroy every [ __ ] thing
and eventually that's [ __ ] that's
crazy eventually they they did that
um they destroyed it all eventually
there's that was definitely the wrong
thing to do
you know what's crazy you should have
just taken and they they did they wanted
that religion to die they just should
have taken that religious
documents away from them stored It Up
the Damn Vatican okay yeah like keep
just keep it and then you're right so
you could study it later uh you know for
future Generations but they didn't think
that way you know you're talking about
Renaissance period and
people were people were intelligent but
they weren't really that forward
thinking and they weren't going like
well you know this is one of the world's
great civilizations you know what I mean
yeah they got child sacrifice and some
weird [ __ ] that was going on but you
don't condemn all of their [ __ ]
writings because of that what are you
talking about you know what I mean I
think he likes saying well because of
Epstein's Island happened we're gonna
[ __ ] destroy all of Western [ __ ]
civilizations writings you know what I
mean just because that one dude because
that [ __ ] those dudes out there on
that island
you know which it was a lot of the stuff
that I would say were abuses that were
happening in mesoamerica it was all
really because of what their Elites were
doing and and their in the religions
that they that they basically fostered
you know
um
they were using that stuff as almost
like a totalitarian theocracy you obey
or you die if you if you disobey me I'll
sacrifice your daughter
uh that's really what what it ended up
being which I don't think that was the
original intent of those religions
that's just what people that's what it
evolved into because you could gain
power that way yeah certain people get
into power right or like and they you
know right they're like okay well this
is the system and I'm gonna use this
system to empower me and what I want to
do
and that's kind of what Cortez and the
the Cortez was saying he was you know he
was telling because he led a Revolt you
know it wasn't a thing where the
Spaniards overthrew the Aztec empire
that no
the Aztecs
fostered a Revolt of a bunch of
Mesoamerican city-states to topple the
Aztec empire it was mostly Indians doing
it not not Spaniards well there wasn't
enough of this there wasn't enough
Spaniards it was the the Spaniards
kicked off an Indian Civil War a lot of
it behind these religious abuses
but these weren't abuses these abuses
that were happening were kind of class
abuses more than anything else and
political stuff it was not a [ __ ]
shouldn't have been used as a way to
condemn the entire [ __ ] system of
that Civilization you know
they've [ __ ] pieced together in the
Huddle so now they know how to write it
there's they need to start teaching that
to the to to people in Mexico so you can
revive that that was a very high-tech
religion or not a high-tech language
it was way ahead of the get the game
nahada was a language based upon emojis
basically yeah that's what they were
emojis yep
the Mexicans had figured out emojis long
before us
and [ __ ] thing yeah yeah emojis
that's some hardcore [ __ ]
and um
they had good uh
uh
virtues good manly virtues of
masculinity and femininity and uh very
much like the Vikings the the Mexicans
were a lot like the Vikings
um
still kind of are
but yeah
every bit as cool as the Egyptians I
don't know if you remember I the weird
thing about it is that I don't remember
it's probably like um because I feel
like they've done a lot of uh you know
research since the time that I was in
school but I kind of feel like when I
was in school
Elementary School Junior High stuff like
that you know when you took your social
studies class or whatever you always
learned about ancient Egypt you always
learned about Greece and Rome and
everything like that you learned about
the Fertile Crescent you learned about
all that kind of stuff but they didn't
really go that much into mesoamerica no
I didn't really learn a lot about that
until later like on my own yeah
um and actually probably not until I got
to college and it's just as old or older
right so I kind of feel like I mean it's
probably better now like I said because
they've done a lot of research since
then but when I was in school in the 80s
I feel like they didn't they barely
talked about mesoamerica it was all
Egypt Greece Rome yeah well that was
more classical education yeah from a
European point of view that's yeah
that's what I'm saying like anything
anything new world they really didn't
yeah they didn't really go that much
into it right they didn't go into like
any kind of like Native American cities
they didn't go into a meso American
stuff they didn't do any of that kind of
stuff like I don't remember learning
like maybe like two [ __ ] percent yeah
of like the world history class was
about that we didn't learn a lot about
Asian history or African History either
in world history it was basically like
European history the amazing thing about
the Mesoamerican civilizations and there
there were several of them and it went
along for a long long time is that in
terms of sheer size they dwarfed
anything in Europe
the size of those cities yeah they were
bigger
far bigger they were huge and big
populations
so it's funny how that kind of
took [ __ ] back seat to Egypt [ __ ]
not Egypt wasn't [ __ ] compared to
[ __ ]
actually Mexico I mean Egypt's awesome
nobody's saying that but it's just like
bigger yeah it just seems like it's it's
weird that you know the Mesoamerican
civilizations were just as large or
larger yeah and just as complex and they
didn't really like I said it's probably
different now I'm not in school now so I
don't know but like when I was in school
in the 80s you didn't learn hardly
anything about this America I didn't
find out I didn't learn about it until
like later on my own like in I like my
college anthropology classes and stuff
and then they kind of went into it but
the Mesoamerican civilizations the Maya
the Aztec were a subset of the Maya they
were Maya too they were just a different
tribe of the Maya that kind of broke off
from it was like a breakaway
civilization but they had a lot of the
same gods
they're bigger than Europe and Egypt
combined in terms of just sheer size and
population the size of the Cities they
were very well developed
in the 1500s I would say they were on
par with uh a par with the feudal Japan
about like that they weren't dealing
with steel yet but they did have metals
they didn't really need steel and
they're in the Warfare was different for
them it was more religious than it was
tactical military types types that was
more about capturing sacrifices to set
to play to pay the blood debt back to to
the Sun God no it's a coexico not
Quetzalcoatl it was uh I forgot what his
name was
uh anyway
it was so the the the the it was a
different scene they all kind of had a
the same Pantheon of gods that they were
worried about
but it's just fascinating fascinating
civilization and they were civilized
uh people said well they weren't
civilized no they had [ __ ] vast
writings and [ __ ] uh really
intelligent uh uh Elite Class of people
uh that could do mathematics and uh
[ __ ] had great poetry and good taste
in things
and some of their writings exist if you
know what they wrote of what they what
they thought of the Conquistadors that
showed up they were marrying their
daughters off especially in the Central
American part they're marrying their
daughters off these guys and then these
Nobles had realized that These Guys
these Spanish guys were middle class and
they were like oh [ __ ] I just kind of
married my daughter off to a dude who's
a scumbag in his own time some of them
were yeah you know what I mean
um and they were like coming over here
thinking you're big [ __ ] yeah we're not
gonna know the difference yeah we saw
this steel and all this [ __ ] that you
could do but you're actually nothing
where you come from and I just married
my daughter off to you so yeah
Blaster once said what happened to your
other cat she's around she's she um
Beijing is she owns the downstairs
so she very very rarely comes upstairs
if she does come upstairs Pookie will
will jump on her on her on her fluffy
tit fluffy tail and go get out of my
territory they've kind of like taken
over Pookie owns upstairs and Beijing
owns downstairs
so Beijing usually like sleeps on the
couch like downstairs
Louis says Jenny I'm a little younger
than you and you're absolutely right
about learning about mesoamerica in
school yeah I just remember not learning
I remember in my world history classes
and I'm talking mainly about like you
know Junior High and a little bit into
like world history in high school I
remember mostly learning about things
from like a very european-centric
you did you didn't even learn about
really like Native American tribes that
were already here like you just learned
about oh here come the pilgrims and you
know they met oh look all these people
were already here and stuff like that
they were still teaching that like it
was a real dumbed-down version yeah and
a lot of us because they didn't know
yeah that's had a lot to do with it they
don't know there's a bunch of weird
things that seem to be ruins of cities
that were Native American
here in North America that they still
don't know really what they are and
they're not really interested in them
because it's not Egypt
there's this fixation on Ancient Egypt I
mean I get it like ancient Egypt like
they're all of that stuff like that's
badass I love all that stuff but it is
kind of like sad that mesoamerica kind
of yeah he's got short shrift it got
kind of I kind of had to learn about it
on my own yeah and one of the things was
that I heard was that well you know
mesoamerica is not that interesting
because it's not that old that was in
the 1500s wait hold on
those mesoamericans have been doing that
[ __ ] for six for [ __ ] thousands of
years of course it's old it'd be as if
ancient Egypt [ __ ] survived until the
1500s that's what I mean they're saying
oh it's not old because we just because
we just turned up inside it didn't exist
before yeah like like it did existence
yeah well it's not old like I said yeah
even when I was in school like even up
until the 80s they still kind of had
they didn't say this outright but the
implication was still it's like oh well
you know the oh the Europeans oh the
Europeans are here so it's like now the
party can get started you know what I
mean it's not like it's not like the
Native Americans the mesoamericans like
all this even like up in Canada and
everything like that like all the
indigenous people it's not like they
hadn't had these complex societies that
have been going on for thousands of
years right they just happened to be
there and it's like oh well now we
acknowledge you so now yeah so now you
can like be in the history books like
nobody cared about what they were doing
before the Europeans showed up it seemed
like which is kind of sad hopefully
they've rectified that I think I think
what happened was is that
scholars in the 18 and 1900s are reading
about it in the 1500s as well that's not
for that wasn't that long ago yeah our
our ancestors saw that so it couldn't
have been that impressive
they they want us to talk about some
[ __ ] that happened thousands of years
ago
all right like well that was a long time
ago
but they're but they [ __ ] just
skimmed over the fact that
6 000 years ago here in the new world
this the the Mayans were doing exactly
what you saw in the 1500s they were
doing that here yeah you know the
reasons here complex civilization so if
you just like they did in Europe so
really showing up in the 1500s you're
very lucky to see it
because you know in the 1500s you
couldn't see ancient Egypt it was long
gone yeah
you know crushed by Rome basically and
then swallowed up by the by the Greeks
by the ptolemies
and then it just became kind of like a
normal modern Arab State you know
uh but that took time you know but you
actually saw an anxious civilization and
that would have been Mexico
Mexico in the 1500s is exactly like that
probably 3000 years before just that it
wouldn't have been there it would have
been further south
because the the the the Aztecs weren't
there for very long uh I don't think
they had been there for longer than a
couple hundred years I think during the
time I think that I think by the time
the Spanish Spaniards had found them I
think Mexico I think Mexico City was
only there or tenno teach law and I
think is what what they called it
um I think I think it had only been
there for a couple hundred years the
cities didn't last that long they
they didn't
they didn't have a technology to
fertilize land so they would build crops
around the city and deplete the soil and
when the soil got depleted
these the crop yield would start [ __ ]
up
so the elites would go well we must be
doing something wrong we're gonna have
to [ __ ] pay back some blood debt to
the Gods and every time he did that
you're also human meat ended up going on
the market so it was kind of late term
abortion and and Welfare you got free
food if you depleted the population so
they'd start to eat the population you
know it's cannibalism
and that would go on until people said
well [ __ ] this I'm leaving this city you
know and that's what would happen that's
why there's all those damn cities
throughout Central America the abandoned
Mesoamerican and Mayan cities is because
you couldn't they couldn't fertilize
land
you know no nitrate no nitrate-based
fertilizers that comes out of the damn
oil refineries the oil
the oil industry makes nitrate based
fertilizer so you without the oil
industry you're not gonna be able to
fertilize too well
you won't be able to run a city you
don't have the technology
um even Rome had problems with it
so
it was a hell of a time to live
because everything would have been
Mystic sized
cropped yields aren't good we did
something wrong
you know
how else could you explain it yeah we we
did exactly what we did last year why is
it not growing you know
Cheryl says uh do you guys put up a tree
or anything yeah we have a tree yeah
tree down there it's true it's just
downstairs plug it in it's got lights
already in it because we lazy one of
these days
um you know not this year obviously
because I'm uh broke dick this year but
I kind of want to get a tree for up here
like just for the show I kind of wanted
one that was kind of not necessarily
green I kind of like the idea of having
like a white tree or a black tree so I
can decorate it for different holidays
so I could have it like in the
background of the different shows so I
could do a Halloween tree I can do all
kind of different stuff that'd be neat
that's one of that's one of my goals but
you know
fake Christmas trees are [ __ ]
expensive man I just can't justify the
[ __ ]
maybe I can just like make a paper one
and like stick it on the wall or some
[ __ ] like that I don't know but yeah so
there's one downstairs like at the
actually at the bottom of the uh
staircase like down in the
down into what's generally supposed to
be the dining room but we don't use it
for a dining room because we don't ever
eat down there so you know
um you know yeah Louie said same here
very European Centric education yeah
it's kind of a shame and honestly like
world history is fascinating but and
like I said I get that they only have a
limited amount of time and you know
they're teaching they're usually
teaching to like you know college
aptitude tests and things like that so
there's a specific amount of things or
number of things they have to get to
and so they can't really
drill down into like really interesting
things so you really kind of have to
learn a lot of stuff on your own but
it's much easier nowadays like I said
because you have the internet so if
you're really interested in a particular
topic you can find out whatever you want
to find out about it but when I look
back on it and I mean I think I had like
a relatively I went to public school
obviously but um you know I I think I
have like had like a really decent
education but when I think about my
history classes I found them interesting
but they were very very European Centric
very european-centric like even
ostensibly I think it was I guess it was
10th grade
um which is
how old was I that'd be 15 16 years old
if you're not from the United States
um I had a world history class and
essentially it was all it was like
European history like I think they maybe
gave like a little bit of a shout out to
like oh and by the way there was like
some stuff going on in China and Japan
and Africa but it's like let's move on
to
talk about like England and France and
all this other kind of stuff you know
what I mean oh and then yay America you
know what I mean it was that kind of
thing
um you know and like I said I get it
there's only so much time in the world's
a big place and history is very long so
there's a lot of stuff you gotta cover
but I do kind of feel like
and I I don't really remember learning
hardly anything about mesoamerica at all
which is like really really sad
so I had to like learn about a lot of
that on my own like later on
Laster one said uh a lot of cats in
Australia are considered Vermin because
they prey on native birds
I understand they can be a good addition
to the family though I could never ever
think of like a cat as vermin they're
just too cute to be Vermin sorry
but the I mean
I don't know I have a really soft spot
for all kind of animals
I have a hard time even I have a hard
time even like
because I know that in Australia they're
like oh kangaroos you know you can shoot
them because they're
you know they're considered Vermin or
you know bunnies and stuff like that I'm
like
I can't really I can't really kill any
animal other than a cockroach [ __ ]
cockroaches but other than that
[ __ ] man I can't even kill a [ __ ]
spider so
that's like a [ __ ] soft I am about
you so I just can't imagine I know cats
kill birds I know and the thing about it
is that well that's kind of why they
kind of tell you
over here and I know people do it anyway
but if you're uh if you have a cat over
here they generally try to tell you like
look if you have like you know mostly
keep them inside like don't let them run
around loose in like the neighborhood I
know a lot of people do because you know
cats want to go outside but
they generally say if you have a cat
like try to keep it inside because it
kills
everything like if you let it run around
outside at night it kills birds and
moles and
all kind of [ __ ] creatures so you
know they're little serial killers cats
are
here that's not a big problem though
yeah I don't hear you let him go and
[ __ ] Eagles get him well see that's
why I'm not really
um I don't really like Pokey going
outside
Beijing will go outside but she doesn't
she just she just sits on the back porch
Pookie used to go outside at our old
place and I wasn't a fan of that but she
would complain until you let her out she
didn't go far she would just kind of go
a little bit like down the backyards and
like sit by the pond
but in this new place she seems less
interested in going outside I think it's
because we have our neighbors have dogs
that are usually like outside and she's
scared of dogs
so okay what time is it it is uh 7 44.
how long have been how long we've been
streaming probably one hour and 49
minutes
and let's see Cheryl says awesome I have
an office tree yeah one of these days
I'll get a tree to go in here so I can
decorate it for different holidays you
know what I mean I'd like to have a
little CR you know a little Christmas
tree and well like I said that that girl
that I like on YouTube Jade the Libra
she has a white Christmas tree
and she decorates it for Christmas
Halloween and also she does like dark
Valentine's Day you know what I mean
like she'll put like black hearts and
like bats and stuff like that on it it's
like actually pretty cool looking
I used to work with a lady that had a
well it wasn't like a full-size tree but
she just had like a little tree that was
like a foot or two tall and she like
kept on her desk and she decorated for
every holiday she had like an Easter
tree she'd hang little eggs on it and
she'd hang little Shamrocks and [ __ ] on
there when it was [ __ ]
uh St Patrick's Day and you know she has
like little ornaments for everything
which I kind of I like that idea but
I don't know at the moment like I said I
can't really justify the expense because
man we were in [ __ ] what was it we're
Lowe's or Home Depot or which one is it
that's bias is that is it Lowe's
um we were on Lowe's the other day
buying some [ __ ] I don't remember what
it was
and um I was looking at the
fake trees and holy [ __ ]
they want a lot of money for fake trees
I mean I I do like the ones that have
the lights already built in them because
I remember being a kid I used to really
like to put up the Christmas tree at my
grandma's house but man nobody wanted to
put the lights on that [ __ ] because how
[ __ ] tedious was that putting that
and nobody likes fluffing it either
that's the thing about the fake trees
you have to put it all together from
last year and you got to like floof it
back out so it looks all even and that
took forever and then you had to like
put all the lights on it and then like
half the [ __ ] strings the lights
didn't work and then you had to go buy
new ones at Walmart and
it was just the whole thing it was the
whole thing
so now they make the ones with the
lights already built in them and they're
all even and stuff but man they cost
like [ __ ] 300 or something for like
300 for what for those fake Christmas
trees that had the lights already built
into them yeah yeah somewhere some of
them were like three hundred dollars
like for the bigger ones but even the
smaller ones were like 140 or something
like that I was like Jesus [ __ ]
Christ I don't have 140 what the [ __ ] do
they think that like I said I'm just
gonna cut one out of [ __ ] paper and
stick it on the wall or something it
doesn't look as cool but
jeez
the hell you think I'm like [ __ ] made
of money what do we look like
millionaires yeah
uh Danny says at least cats don't [ __ ]
up in people's yards while the owner
doesn't even clean it up
I hate dog walkers well that's the thing
okay now that the house where we used to
live
and I think I mentioned it before we
were like our the back of our house like
the the backyard where we used to live
had like the the fence and then it was
like the um the Seminole Wekiva Trail I
think is what that was called so it kind
of goes through the whole County
we don't live in Seminole County anymore
now we live in Lake County but
um so people would walk their dogs along
there not I have to say though 99.99 of
the people that walk their dogs on there
cleaned up after their dogs
like you would see them like Skip and
they'd had the little plastic bag and
they would scoop up the [ __ ] and
everything like that I'm like well good
on you I very very very rarely saw dog
[ __ ] on that trail which is mind-blowing
but yeah people do kind of like walk
their dogs and let their dogs kind of
poop everywhere so
so that is one thing I mean at least
cats have the decency to bury their poop
there's that
Cheryl says I got a cat I can't keep it
in too if you don't let him out he'll
piss in your bed
that's what I mean I think
I don't really I don't know I don't I
don't like
letting cats run around outside
not even so much yeah it sucks that they
kill birds and other animals and stuff
like that but just because of danger to
them I don't want them to get run over
by cars or on that many or things like
yeah but I mean yeah one cat can't kill
that many but if everybody lets their
cats out and like we're you know it's
just kind of like oh I'm gonna it's the
same thing it's like oh I'm just one
person and I'm gonna throw this [ __ ]
candy wrap around the ground it's like
yeah it's just one candy wrapper but if
every [ __ ] if every [ __ ] does that
then there's gonna be cancer that's just
that's just the way life is though an
animal I'm just joking well no one but
I'm just saying that if you have a pet
cat I just think it's generally better
to keep them indoors well they're a
domestic cat they're domestic animals
right basically all of you I mean I
don't really like I did even at the old
house which was kind of safer I didn't
really like Pokey going outside but she
would complain if she didn't once once
we moved to this one she didn't really
seem all that interested in going
outside anymore which I was happy about
I've been watching all these videos from
these Eastern European that I guess
their laws are different they allow them
to have big cats and they have as long
as they have their house set up properly
they can have a big cat
and uh they have guys that have American
mountain lions and black panthers and
they keep it like a dog
I would have thought that those things
were vicious but no loving I mean if you
raise it from a baby well because the
thing about it is that domesticated cats
they call it domesticated cats that
people keep in their houses
they're not really that domesticated
they're not that far off of wild yeah if
anything they act similar this girl's
got a black panther
and she keeps posting and that thing
looks more docile than a house cat
I would put it on par with a dog
but it grabs her and licks on her and um
gets in the bed with her you know just
obviously just loves people
and they put a collar on it and she goes
out and walks it and it goes up and
greets people and
you know and that was kind of thinking
well you know
the ancient Romans had those kept them
in their houses so big lions
so I guess it's been going on for a long
time
like I said if you raise it from uh hit
from a kitten yeah so it just sees you
as like it's Mom or like part of its
little pride or whatever what I thought
was amazing is it saw people that it
didn't know as as
friendly she's got well I guess because
it was raised around people so it didn't
see you as food she's got it she's got
the thing on the leash and it's just
walking up to people and you know giving
them a hug stand up on the back leg give
them a hug licking them going on to the
next one that's badass yeah let's go get
a baby tiger
I don't have the resources
yeah I guess you have to you have to
keep those things well fed
well yeah they eat a lot and they're
very large yeah and yeah big as a human
yeah well bigger bigger yeah well the
one it's a leopard though uh it's as big
as a human
it didn't it's not as big as a tiger a
tiger is bigger than a than a human yeah
I'd say it's about the size of a human
maybe 160 pounds
uh size of a large meaty dog maybe you
know besides the Great Dane maybe not
even that tall
um but all the the the behavior facial
expressions the
body language
like a cat like a house cat you could
read the cat perfectly like I said
they're not domesticated cats are not
that different from Wildcats as far as
Behavior goes leopards looking at you
with love in the face and love in the
eyes yeah come here you just you know
what I mean you just go okay that I can
tell that that animal's friendly you
know
on its back pet my stomach all that pet
my belly all that
and uh
some people say well that's dangerous
and you go well those [ __ ] dogs are
dangerous too if a dog gets pissed off
and can kill a human you know a human
can kill a human a dog can kill a human
anything can kill anything
and from what I'm saying to these damn
cats these big cats they don't look any
more dangerous than a big dog
you know yeah I mean if you had a great
dane that decided he didn't like you
know maybe you would also be [ __ ] yeah
because they were bigger than me yeah
but uh it looked they looked chilled out
to me
you know they're trusting it with the
family children
playing with this thing you know and
it's just
the family yeah I mean I don't know if
I'd go quite that far but they were uh
yeah I don't know little kids playing
with the leopard maybe I'd feel
different if I raised it like from a
baby thank you Ian England thank you
very much for the Super Chat it says
Wasabi [ __ ]
[Laughter]
um yeah and uh Danny earlier said yeah
foxes like to eat cats yeah I don't
really like I don't like the thought of
like Pookie running around outside
because if I mean if she was outside and
like something happened to her I would
just like ever all those animals are
cute Fox is cute [ __ ] wolves and
coyotes are cute they're all cute yeah
they're all okay they're all cute uh I
don't believe in killing any of that
[ __ ] I used to kill that [ __ ] but when I
was kid shot coyotes and stuff
but you know didn't know much about them
they just I had orders you know [ __ ]
coyotes are not supposed to be in the
deer patch because they run the deer
they're just dogs
like any other dogs you know
saw that they mean that'd be like
shooting a dog yeah it's like only a
psychopath could shoot a dog well I
wasn't thinking it that way at the time
you know but it's just like yeah it's
like shooting a dog and then uh raccoons
I always thought raccoons were kind of
vicious the raccoons are friendly
um they're vicious if you they're
cornered they don't know you but you can
see the pets people that have them as
pets uh you can even feed wild ones and
and and they'll they'll warm up to you
they got a guy who every day 30 of them
show up to his house and he's handing
out food hot dogs and [ __ ] got them all
giving them names and they're like
dancing and being clowns
[Laughter]
so you know they're just little clouds
and uh most of those animals uh if they
get to know you're friendly so
I mean if you're a source of food and
you're being cool to them right then
I I don't see any reason why they would
turn on you big difference in the
personality between prey animals you
know like deer and caribou
you know they they reproducing large
numbers they're used to being preyed on
they're not very intelligent compared to
like predators and and uh generalists
you know like a dog as well and they're
a lot more nervous because they have to
be like they're more skittish to be that
way
but there's uh animals that are kind of
like
generalists or uh or apex predators
they're a lot smarter and you shouldn't
really be [ __ ] with them that much I
mean I've seen that you know those
[ __ ] golden pandas
yeah and then it's called a red panda a
red panda oh my God that's like some of
the world's biggest stand up on two feet
like a person and they're real uh
friendly and intelligent
and humans fall in that same
I'm not one of these people that's like
oh you can't eat animals like a vegan or
thing no you could eat them it's just
that there's a hierarchy and what should
be eaten and what shouldn't be eaten
things that don't reproduce in large
numbers predators
generalist type animals like bears and
[ __ ] don't eat them there's not that
many of them they didn't evolve to be
eaten
um
so they don't they don't reproduce in
large numbers and they're they tend to
be more intelligent
so I don't believe in eating those and
even if you do eat animals I mean it
should go without saying but it's like
you know make that animal suffer as
little as possible yeah fast ditch
how was it Halal Slaughter you know
[ __ ] uh just not you know [ __ ]
don't eat them alive or try to fry them
alive I saw some of this thing as dog
Festival in China where a dude is trying
to hold a [ __ ] domesticated dog into
the bottom of a searing hot pan trying
to cook it alive see man don't show it
to me yeah to make it more tender
and I was just like no man I can't like
I said that's some Psychopaths psycho
only a psycho that's a psychopath and
dogs begging he's trying to put the lid
on the [ __ ] pot
see I don't understand how you could do
that no but I'm still like I'll never be
that hungry sorry yeah I think that they
were getting off on it I would starve
before I would do that yeah and I'd have
to [ __ ] go uh berserk in a situation
like that let these dogs out you know
what I mean yeah I think I would too I'd
hold that dude's head into the bottom of
that pair
and I know a lot of people think this is
[ __ ] up because I think I've mentioned
this before like particularly like in
some of my horror movie reviews because
you know how like a lot of horror movies
will be like oh we're gonna show you how
[ __ ] up this [ __ ] is we'll like kill a
cute cat or a dog or something like that
and I'm always just like man kill all
the people you want in a horror movie
like leave the [ __ ] cats and dogs
alone or with the birds or the spiders
or anything and I know people think
that's [ __ ] up but it's like look
humans are like you know supposedly
we're we have these complex brains and
everything like that we know better
supposed to know better you're supposed
to know better yeah animals generally do
not
um they're generally innocent they just
kind of do what they do and I was just
kind of like I don't that's like it's
like to me it's like killing a baby it's
like killing a child even is what that's
like even though even those predatory
big cats do not eat animals alive
they'll grab a uh they'll grab a gazelle
by the throat and choke it out
they're not even [ __ ] piercing the
skin
they're just choking its windpipe and
and suffocating it before they eat it
you know they're not eating that animal
alive
uh now I have seen videos of one of them
is choking it out a zebra and then
another another [ __ ] lion is gonna
[ __ ] hit I'm gonna get this leg and
just start eating I'll just start eating
on the legs but that's not that was not
the intent you know they're competing
over the food
um
when left to their own the animal will
kill a a a a big cat will kill the
animal before they eat it
you know they won't eat it alive
but then I saw another Chinese dude I
don't pick on the Chinese but they're
bad at it they eat things alive so I did
reach in there and [ __ ] grab a
[ __ ] live frog and start chewing it
raw from the head first
because he thought it would cure a
[ __ ] Cove I think or it was some kind
it was part of Chinese medicine
now I know it's a frog frogs are pretty
simple
I don't I don't even like that to be
honest would you choose why would you
choose something from the head alive
first you know what I mean I'm just
gonna I mean just from like a gross
point that's just [ __ ] gross that's
like some Fear Factor it's like that big
you know it's a big frog
I was just like I don't want to be cured
of anything that bad yeah sorry I don't
um well that's the thing like look and I
know you guys might think I'm weird and
look I love seafood and stuff I don't
even like that hole we're gonna pop the
Lobster in the boiling water alive I
don't I I even kind of feel I don't I
don't feel good about that to be honest
yeah well most Cooks won't do that
they'll just take the damn knife and go
right through the brain first yeah yeah
do that like don't put the [ __ ] in there
a lot that's [ __ ] up like yeah I know
they're just like insects and all that
but still I don't even like remember
when we were talking the other day that
I had watched um that uh movie with the
shad and the kingdom of the spiders from
the 70s and I said in that I had
forgotten because I hadn't seen it since
I was a kid but I had forgotten that
some of them like actually did stay up
on the Tarantulas in there and I'm like
oh I don't like that I don't like that I
like spiders I don't you know what I
said Tom doesn't but I I like spiders
and particularly tarantulas I'm just
like yeah that's not cool that's not
cool some of the dogs are bred to be
yeah but they weren't bred to be eaten
by us okay I could actually you know
breed humans to be eaten give me a bunch
of him hey I read a book like that
called tenderism it's one of the most
[ __ ] up books I've ever read it
doesn't mean that you're supposed to do
that
um
if you haven't read it read that book
it's [ __ ] up a lot of what happened
what a lot of what happened in China and
Vietnam also and even to a certain
extent Thailand uh was kind of unnatural
with their um dietary practices because
uh communism uh totally [ __ ]
destroyed their normal uh [ __ ] menu
and they started to do things like
eating things they normally wouldn't eat
and they started eating bugs and [ __ ]
eating cockroaches
um that wasn't normal that was the
extreme poverty and deprivation that
came from
cataclysms that happened during the
Great Leap Forward you know a [ __ ]
miles greatly enforce that wasn't their
normal food
yeah I mean you got to do what you got
to do like if you're gonna starve and
that's like the only thing around then
yeah you know what I mean it's like
you're right because you know look at
like the you know people have resorted
to cannibalism like eating other humans
like in dire situations like No One's
Gonna blame them for that
but there was like uh I saw some Thai
Cooks Thai chefs they were cooking some
fantastic [ __ ] and people started
bringing up the insects and all the
weird stuff and they're like oh no no no
no that's not Thai food they're like
that happened during an extreme during a
famine because of Communism and [ __ ]
Civil Wars and [ __ ] that happens is that
was not traditional Thai food they don't
so that's not on their menu yeah I mean
some of that stuff too to be fair like
[ __ ] stunt stuff oh well if people
remember it because it's weird yeah so
it's like you know people aren't eating
that all the time right you know what
I'm saying I mean then like uh
there were stuff in the south
that was sucking not normal food but
some of it still lives on
grits grits were not normal
grits were something were something that
we were eating we made it out of damn
cattle feed I mean at least grits aren't
kind of like it's just corn alive though
it's not like eating a lime frog or
anything we were using like cracked corn
that you feed cattle you put lye on that
and a bunch of water and it'll poof up
and then you can blend that and then you
can make something kind of like polenta
out of it and that wasn't delicious yeah
it's delicious but that's why that
stayed on but that was more of a civil
war survival food grits and uh chances
are I believe
crawfish were not was not originally
something that people were supposed to
eat
they were called Mud Bugs you know uh
they're part of the Southern Cuisine now
but
according to my grandmother people
didn't eat those
and we're supposed to be eating those
those were things that grew naturally
in the uh the rod off troughs on the
either side of the roads because you
know we didn't we didn't have gutters we
had these little [ __ ] what'd you call
those Jenny ditches it's just called
[ __ ] there's ditches on either side of
the road so they had [ __ ] crawfish
growing them and people go in there and
getting them cooking those boiling them
in
spice and spices
like shrimp they were like little bitty
little bitty [ __ ] lobsters is what
they were like
and um evidently that wasn't like a
respectable thing to do to eat those you
know but they're around
it'd be like
you're not supposed to be eating
armadillo
but
you had people eating them
eating an armadillo is about like eating
a maggot they're [ __ ] filthy they
carry leprosy
well you know
they're just a little carrying dead
that's just what their little niche is
yeah
and they serve a purpose in nature just
like vultures do instead no one's eating
vultures but armadillos are essentially
like vultures they eat carrion my Cajun
someone got to do it my Cajun uncles and
cousins would eating the [ __ ] out of
those things
I can't imagine that would taste good
they would eat [ __ ]
dealer on the half shells what they call
it they serve they just ate that [ __ ]
because it's free yeah it's free because
it's rude yeah they're scraping running
them over they'd see them on the road
and run them over bam get him
and then they'd [ __ ] make that see I
can't fill it up with like [ __ ]
stuffing like uh turkey dressing type
stuff
[ __ ] put it all back in the Shell
hungry and then you're [ __ ] with
Cajun spices and [ __ ] they thought it
was [ __ ] great
well I wouldn't eat that no I wouldn't
either
I'm not a Cajun though they [ __ ] eat
everything
Zach says would you guys ever own a dog
um I'm not a verse to owning a dog
um but they're outside creatures for the
most part I kind of feel like I've
always been a cat person
more than anything we had like a couple
of dogs growing up I was never a big fan
of like I love dogs but I was never a
big fan of owning one to me they seem to
needy they're too labor intensive
um just it's more like having well let's
see I don't know I don't want to say
that because having Pookie is kind of
like having a kid too but she's very
dog-like for a cat yeah she's like a lot
needier than a normal cat would be but
even she is like
will sleep most of the time but still
like when she's awake she's totally up
in your face like one to get involved in
everything you're doing so she's kind of
like a dog in that way but
I don't know I just I've never been a
big fan of like having dogs
I had someone I was a kid like my family
had them but we mostly had cats and I'm
just more of a cat person
cats are more like
my personality I guess
they're kind of more I don't want to say
they're aloof because all of them aren't
but
they're kind of more independent you
know what I mean and I kind of like that
better
um Louie says bears eat their prey alive
and Ben says there's a Chinese tick
tocker who got into all sorts of trouble
for eating a live shark on screen
yeah like what like
I get you're trying to get views and
everything like that but that's just
like stunting and you know why I I don't
I don't
why would you do that
for eating fresh food and and God eating
it alive is as fresh as it can be well I
guess but I saw a [ __ ] video of one
dude he's [ __ ] walking he's got a
damn
um raccoon and he's holding it by the
tail upside down and walking it and it's
the raccoon's like let me go let me go
like what the [ __ ] you're doing man and
[ __ ] uh sea milk the guy who's making
the videos he was he was an american guy
he said what is that what are you doing
with that [ __ ] and he called he called
it in the subtitles tree dog he says I'm
gonna eat this tree dog you know and
he's like oh man but if I can
I don't know how he got that raccoon
they were out in the woods
just caught a raccoon by Aunt I guess
nobody you
man
you can eat raccoons there's not much
meat there
and it's not real good quality meat why
are you bothering that's [ __ ]
survival level you know like I said if
you're out like in the woods and you're
starving to death yeah I can understand
it but okay but like other than that why
would you it's not very good quality
meat you know what I mean and there's so
much easier things to eat I mean it's so
easy to to fish and to catch fish and
it's much better quality meat than
raccoon
yeah raccoon's kind of lean and gamey
and tough
and there's not much meat there you know
I mean they're probably
cat would probably be better than than
raccoon
well I'm not even I'm not even saying
that that's saying much you know what I
mean
there's just that's just not a good food
animal
you know there's not much well like we
said in general predators are not good
food yeah yeah in general
like I said if you're starving to death
then that's different then you know you
just eat whatever you can get your hands
on but like you said I don't the easiest
meat you can get in the wild and I'm
telling you all I got experience in this
[ __ ] it's fish yeah it's so easy I mean
if you're by and you don't even have to
like so easy but you just like run a
[ __ ] truck line you don't even have
to [ __ ] sit out there it's
more fun and kind of more expedient you
know if you want to get something right
now to [ __ ] go ahead and throw a lure
in there and you don't even need to buy
a lure you could make a lure you don't
even need a raw you don't need a rod
all right you look how Africans fish out
in Africa they'll just have the line and
they'll sit there and like that and
throw the [ __ ] line The Lure out into
the water and Pull It in with their
hands and then they'll wrap it around
something round that they'll find like
that and then then they'll fight the
fish that way and they might have a
glove on or they may not you don't even
need a reel you can just do with a line
and they're bringing a fish that big and
just sit there and then a few hours have
three or four of those man that's a
[ __ ] meal yeah and it's easy to clean
it Cooks quickly it tastes good it
tastes good you don't need much and it's
good seasoning and yeah it's real good
so the water
is the easiest way to get food there's
so many [ __ ] little sea creatures and
[ __ ] water creatures and or you make
a [ __ ] Crab Trap which is easy to
make yeah I mean me and my dad used to
Crab Trap yeah you just have a damn two
liter bottle and put a hole in it or
something big with a hole in it and put
a little bit of meat in the bottom of it
and wire it in there and throw it in on
there in a line and pull it up every now
and then you'll find [ __ ] crabs in it
you know you throw them into a [ __ ]
bucket of water until you got enough of
them you're gonna boil them crabs up
yeah there's just all kinds of free food
out there if you're hungry
um eating [ __ ] like [ __ ] raccoons and
squirrels is a waste of time now you can
kill a hundred squirrels and barely get
a decent meal out of it you know it just
seems like too much trouble too much
trouble yeah
fish is like so much easier and there's
so much more meat and it's so much more
nutritious
well the nutrition's good on all of it
it's just that there's more of it and
it's easier and it doesn't cook as it
doesn't take as long to cook and it's
and to be fair it's nice it's not as
cute yeah it's not it's not a cute
creature
that it's easier I mean I have seen some
cute fish I'm not saying that but I'm
just saying yeah it's not fuzzy it's
easier to get yeah you know fish yeah
fish is much easier so
you're kind of hosed if you don't like
seafood though
like my Trotline is the easiest way like
my sister's shoes and you don't know how
to take the Trot Line away it's just a
big old [ __ ] rope yeah you just leave
it there all the time it's like like
just a rope going across the water from
One Tree to the next go check it every
night fishing with fishing line about
three feet of it with a hook on the on
the end of each one of them you just
pull it up every now and then you're
gonna see a [ __ ] fish on there you
can swim out there and get the fish if
you have to or you can have somebody
over there on on tie and Pull It in it's
better to just swim out there and get
him
you know unless which you may not want
to do that if it's real cold but if it's
in the South and it's hot and getting in
that water is not a big deal just strip
down
you know don't get eaten by alligator
yeah strip down and you might instead of
underwear beware and have shorts on
underneath instead of your underwear and
[ __ ] just go out there and go get him
and [ __ ] get get the fish off and put
them on a [ __ ] [ __ ] uh fishing uh
what do you call
oh [ __ ] what are you going
just put a [ __ ]
strength to its Gill you know what I
mean and then so I can put them down
here so he's all on the end of a line
and swim back with the fish and see
and then you have a [ __ ] take them
home and clean those fish
I have all kinds of food
you know you'll never go hungry if
you've got water around I mean to be
honest if somebody told me that I
couldn't eat like chicken or beef or
anything like that but I could just eat
fish I would be I would I would miss
like steak and turkey and stuff like
that but I wouldn't be all that upset
like because I really really like
seafood a lot now here's the problem
somebody was saying well if the
apocalypse ever happens you know what I
mean I can I'll just get my [ __ ]
rifle and I'll go hunt [ __ ] deer and
it doesn't work that way because it's
not gonna be just you out there in that
situation it's gonna be millions of
people out there and you're gonna eat up
the [ __ ] land it's the same with the
fish
okay depending on where you live
but uh
you have to be somewhere out in the
middle of nowhere
um
because
although you gotta look at it this way
they were they were [ __ ] famines
happening in the Soviet Union and there
were people up in the country of Russia
that didn't even know that it was
happening
because it was mostly only happening to
people that were in cities and towns and
they were reliant on that system but
there were people up in the [ __ ]
Siberia or [ __ ] in the [ __ ]
country they didn't even know there was
a [ __ ] didn't even know the they
didn't even know that there was a
[ __ ] communist takeover of the
government they were just living in
[ __ ]
Shacks you know log cabins
he in England said the absolute worst
feeling I ever had killing something was
a little barn owl guy hit it on the
highway and it ripped off one of its
wings oh yeah conservation guy called me
and asked me to take care of it man I
love owls and like barn owls are so
[ __ ] cute they're with their little
heart-shaped faces and stuff oh I would
be like [ __ ] heartbroken if I hit one
with the car like we came we were coming
back from the club well no we weren't
actually I think we were yeah maybe we
were coming back from somewhere like one
night and I think we hit a raccoon and I
still feel bad about that yeah we
couldn't avoid it there was like a bunch
of them like Crossing yeah
um wait so it's like Tammy says owning a
dog is like having a permanent baby yeah
and Cheryl said dog is like having a
toddler I like both but the dog is way
more in your face yeah I mean like I
said Pookie is in your face when she's
awake like she sleeps a lot during the
day because she's a cat but when she's
awake I mean she'll jump on my desk she
sits on my keyboard so I can't get
anywhere so he says she shits on your
keyboard it's what it sounds like you
said no she said something yeah she
hasn't [ __ ] on my keyboard sound like
she sounded like you said that no she
just she jumps up on the desk and then
like she kind of like she Parks she like
kind of lays out like that and she's
like what oh you wanted to type no
you're not allowed to and then she's
like and then she falls asleep so I'm
like I'm going like that like typing
over here it's like that so well you
want to go ahead and shut it down we've
been on for how long for almost three
two hours and 21 minutes we I think we
can shut it down I'll make us something
to eat you hungry yeah we'll make it
something yeah I'm kind of hungry okay
okay uh Zach says I do wish cats showed
affection like dogs do I think they do
they do I think it depends on the cat
yeah
um because I have heard people saying
it's like oh cats are so aloof and stuff
like that I think that that's maybe
people that because cats are individuals
like people are like if dogs are too I
guess
um and if you've always had cats that
were kind of aloof because when I was
growing up we always had cats that were
kind of like that but
what since we've had Pookie she's
um a lot different than a lot of other
cats and try to get up on your chest and
look at you you awake she's just always
whatever you're doing if you make a
noise anywhere in the house she's gonna
come and see what you're doing yeah
she's gonna jump up in that [ __ ] be like
what are you doing can I help you in
some way or can I like help you put the
laundry away or just roll around in it
or something what's this what are you
putting together
[Laughter]
bookcase and then yeah then he freaks
out
whoa make a noise and then she runs back
and then runs back you okay yeah
is funny like yeah I mean I'll be in
near the office and like I hear her like
she comes around the corner of them to
like the bathroom wow wow wow wow and
I'm just like what what do you want
it's just like she wants to she wants to
jump up on the sink so I can brush her
Perfection to a cat as you pet me you
pet me yeah you pet me that that's
that's that's well me and her have a
head butt thing yeah
like she'll do it she'll do it with Tom
sometimes but that's like me and her
thing okay they're asking for night of
the comment review all right yeah we'll
get around to it eventually we'll get
around the night of the comment yeah we
will I think it's actually on it might
be on 2B actually because I I might have
put it in the poll
that went up this morning if I remember
correctly because I think it's isn't it
set at Christmas time
yeah it's set at Christmas time
so I think I put in the poll so if
you're if you're on patreon go vote for
it
and we'll talk about it although like I
said we still haven't done the movie
Very Special for this week which was
supposed to be Chinatown but it'll go up
tomorrow probably I'm gonna go uh start
getting uh stuff to eat ready okay what
you can make I don't know I'm gonna go
see what we have we're gonna go see what
we have yeah I got I got already got
macaroni and cheese made well we had a
little bit of that a few hours ago but
okay that sounds good all right
so hopefully you have uh you guys have a
good Friday night and have a good day
tomorrow like I said Sunday we'll be
back doing a movie review it'll probably
be Pulp Fiction because like I said
Louie uh thank you very much Louie sent
us Pulp Fiction and Reservoir Dogs which
we already did and um somebody asked
like David June asked us to do hateful
eight also so we might do that as well
and we will probably end up doing none
of the comment I have been wanting to do
night of the comment for a long time so
you know it's not just coming out of
nowhere
all right so we'll see you guys again on
Sunday I'm gonna try and get some videos
put up tomorrow hopefully our Chinatown
uh review will get put up tomorrow and
my best horror movies of 1979 will
either go up tomorrow or Sunday like
whenever I get like I started writing it
but I haven't like recorded it yet but
it'll probably go up this weekend
sometime too so be on the lookout for
that and uh yeah we'll see you guys
again on Sunday so have a good weekend
up until then good night